- Bonjour, Monsieur le Président.
- Bonjour.
Merci d'avoir accepté
cette interview.
Merci de prendre le temps.
C'est votre première interview audiovisuelle
depuis un petit peu plus d'un mois.
C'était pendant l'été.
Aujourd'hui, sur les réseaux sociaux,
notre travail est suivi
par plusieurs millions de jeunes,
et donc forcément, on voit au quotidien,
avec mon équipe de journalistes,
les différents sujets qui reviennent souvent,
les inquiétudes aussi
qui sont très présentes
chez une partie des jeunes.
Aujourd'hui, c'est la rentrée.
On va évidemment parler d'éducation,
mais pas que.
On va parler de tout un tas de sujets
qui concernent notre génération,
des sujets d'inégalité,
des sujets de précarité des jeunes,
des sujets aussi environnementaux
forcément,
qui concernent
notamment notre génération.
Alors évidemment, je le dis aussi
pour ceux qui nous regardent,
on ne pourra pas aborder
tous les sujets aujourd'hui.
L'idée pour nous, c'est de faire
une sélection
sur les sujets qui nous paraissent
les plus importants
au vu des retours qu'on a pu avoir.
Et puis, à partir de là,
on va faire en sorte de creuser
chacun de ces sujets.
Si ça vous va, on va pouvoir commencer
tout de suite.
Ça me va très bien.
- Beaucoup de sujets.
On va commencer tout de suite
avec un enjeu, je pense,
qui nous concerne tous.
Aujourd'hui en France,
selon les chiffres de Santé Publique France,
un jeune sur cinq
souffre de troubles dépressifs.
Plus inquiétant encore, le nombre
de tentatives de suicide chez les jeunes
atteint des records.
Plus encore d'ailleurs que pendant le Covid.
Pour ne rien arranger,
on a des services de psychiatrie
qui sont surchargés,
qui appellent à l'aide
face à une détresse très importante
des jeunes dans cette situation.
On est la septième puissance
économique mondiale,
selon les derniers chiffres.
Les moyens économiques potentiels,
ils sont là où ils pourraient être là.
La santé, le bien-être de la population
me semble,
et je pense qu'on sera d'accord là-dessus,
être un élément prioritaire
pour un chef d'État.
Les chiffres, pourtant, sont alarmants.
Comment la situation
peut-elle être aussi grave ?
D'abord, merci de commencer
par ce sujet qui,
je pense, ne date pas d'hier,
et s'est beaucoup révélé pendant le Covid,
on en a parlé, où je pense
qu'il y a eu de la solitude, beaucoup,
et j'ai été frappé, en tout cas,
même dans les débats, ça sortait beaucoup.
Mais c'est là.
Alors, est-ce qu’on ne dépense pas assez
en termes de santé dans notre pays ?
Non, on est l'un des pays
qui dépense le plus,
et on l'a beaucoup augmenté
en sortie de Covid
pour mieux payer nos médecins à l'hôpital,
nos paramédicaux,
pour investir dans notre système.
C'est un des enjeux pour moi,
c'est une de mes priorités.
Si je devais dire, l'école, la santé,
l'écologie sont les trois priorités
en termes de service public dans le pays.
On a un jeune sur cinq
qui souffre de troubles...
Donc, comment répondre à ce sujet ?
D'abord 1, diagnostiquer.
C'est aussi pour ça qu'on a décidé,
cette rentrée, on systématise
de diagnostiquer tous les troubles,
pas que santé mentale,
mais entre autres.
Donc poser un diagnostic sur des troubles,
c'est hyper important.
Et comment est-ce qu'on fait
auprès des étudiants ?
Juste là-dessus,
parce que c'est un des éléments,
donc on peut en parler tout de suite.
Il y a des études qui ont été faites
sur le nombre de psychologues
par université, par étudiant.
En France, on est à un psychologue
pour 15 000 étudiants.
C'est dix fois moins
que les recommandations internationales.
Le deuxième problème qu'on a,
j'allais y venir, c'est en effet
qu'on n'a pas assez de professionnels,
d'abord de psychiatrie.
Donc nous avons lancé ce travail,
on a réinvesti dans ce sujet,
on est en train de le faire.
On met dix ans, au moins,
à former un psychiatre,
puisqu'en fait c'est un jeune
qui va faire des années de médecine,
puis qui choisira cette spécialité.
On fait tout aussi pour revaloriser
cette spécialité qui était aussi
moins prise par les jeunes
qui sortaient de leurs études de médecine.
Et la psychiatrie est un des secteurs
qui souffrent le plus,
dans nos hôpitaux
comme dans le libéral.
Donc on a investi sur ce sujet.
On va continuer de le faire.
Et à la fin du travail qu'on a conduit
sous mon premier mandat,
on a décidé aussi d'ouvrir
aux psychologues, que vous avez cités,
parce qu'il n'y avait, en quelque sorte,
pas de lien entre les deux.
Donc, maintenant, on a créé des forfaits,
particulièrement pour nos étudiants,
qui, quand ils ont justement
une telle souffrance ou de tels troubles,
d'avoir la possibilité d'avoir un forfait
qui est remboursé par la sécurité sociale
de plusieurs heures auprès d'un psychologue.
Donc il y a le sujet de la psychiatrie,
on est d'accord, et la psychologie.
C'est une nuance parfois mal comprise
et qui est importante à faire.
Le psychiatre est un médecin,
le psychologue est un paramédical.
Mais vous parlez de formation de dix ans,
ce que j'entends complètement.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas d'un psychologue.
Mais l'urgence, elle est maintenant.
Elle n'est pas dans dix ans.
On a des remontées
de la part d'hôpitaux psychiatriques,
de services qui disent qu'ils sont
littéralement débordés,
qu'ils mettent en danger des jeunes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
de faire correctement leur métier.
D'abord sur la psychiatrie,
après on parlera des psychologues.
Le besoin n'est pas dans dix ans.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut faire ?
Alors, le besoin...
Première chose, si je reprends
les choses dans le bon ordre,
1, diagnostic, 2, comprendre
comment ces situations se créent,
et essayer de travailler sur la prévention.
Et elle se créé parce qu'il y a du stress,
justement, chez des jeunes
collégiens, lycéens, puis étudiants.
Parfois sur des questions écologiques,
on y reviendra,
sur les questions d'avenir,
un manque de bienveillance du système.
Et donc, il y a tout ce qu'on doit faire
et qu'on est en train de développer
pour mettre plus de bienveillance
dans notre système scolaire et estudiantin.
3 : il y a la prise en charge médicale.
Plus c'est pris en charge tôt,
plus on arrive à encadrer.
On ne va pas réussir
à créer des psychiatres
dans les années qui viennent comme ça,
je ne vais pas vous mentir.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans l'immédiat ?
La seule chose qu'on peut faire,
c'est de consolider les postes qui sont là,
c'est d'en former davantage,
mais ça va prendre des années,
et c'est de les aider à déléguer des actes
qu'ils font dans d'autres structures.
Donc, plus on s'y prend tôt,
avec ce qu'on a fait sur les psychologues,
plus on a des jeunes qui ne tombent pas
dans des formes aiguës
et ne se retrouvent pas
dans les urgences psychiatriques.
Plus on développe des maisons
des adolescents qui permettent,
pour les jeunes qui commencent
à avoir des troubles,
d'être accompagnés, plus on évite ça.
Mais il n'y a pas de solution miracle
pour avoir d'un seul coup
plusieurs milliers de psychiatres en plus
dans notre pays, parce qu'il faut les former.
Donc, on est d'accord,
psychiatrie et psychologie.
Pour la psychiatrie, ce que vous dites,
c'est que dans l'immédiat,
il n'y aura pas plus de moyens
mis dans les services de psychiatrie,
Il y a des moyens ; la difficulté,
c'est de garder les médecins que nous avons,
d'essayer de garder ceux qui sont prêts.
Même en les gardant, on ne fera pas face,
donc c'est un enjeu important.
Il y a un enjeu qui est important,
c'est d'avoir un continuum.
En fait, pour tout, quelle est la clé ?
C'est de mieux diagnostiquer,
de mieux prévenir,
et de mieux nous organiser
sur les formes les plus aiguës.
Quel est le problème qu'on a eu
sur la santé mentale des jeunes ?
C'était un continent caché,
on en parlait pas.
Donc on diagnostiquait très mal,
on prévenait encore moins bien.
Et du coup, on a eu beaucoup de jeunes,
et il y a eu un pic en Covid et après-Covid,
qui sont allés
vers les formes les plus aiguës.
Et donc ça a complètement écrasé
des services d'urgences en psychiatrie,
de pédopsychiatrie aussi,
pour les plus jeunes.
Et la vérité, ils étaient déjà en souffrance
parce qu'ils manquaient de professionnels.
Donc, sur la psychiatrie,
on comprend que ce sera une difficulté,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de nouveauté
qui sera annoncée dans ce cadre-là.
Mais sur la question de la prévention...
Alors, juste pour être clair,
on a monté des travaux en 2021,
qui ont donné lieu à des conclusions,
qui nous ont permis de remettre de l'argent
en formation et en moyens sur la psychiatrie
et le lien entre psychiatres et psychologues,
comme je le disais.
Et là, il y a un travail qui est en cours
pour la pédiatrie
et entre autres la santé mentale
des enfants et des adolescents,
sur lequel on va mettre des moyens aussi.
Pourquoi on a des étudiants
qui décompensent ?
C'est souvent parce qu'ils avaient
des problèmes depuis plusieurs années
qui n'ont pas été détectés,
ni pris en charge.
Donc il y a la question des psychiatres.
C'est des études qui sont longues.
Ça prend du temps à se mettre en place.
En parallèle,
il y a la question des psychologues,
qui sont dans un cadre différent,
qui peuvent être présents
au sein de l'université,
pour justement faire ce travail
de prévention auprès des étudiants.
Mais ça peut être aussi
le cas pour les enfants.
Ce que je disais, et je me permets de le dire
parce que j'en ai parlé ce week-end
avec beaucoup de professionnels du secteur,
pour comprendre ce qu'il en était.
On est aujourd'hui à un psychologue,
dans les universités,
pour 15 000 étudiants.
C'est dix fois moins que ce qu'il faudrait
selon les recommandations internationales.
Dix fois moins.
est-ce qu'on peut réellement
faire de la prévention, qui est essentielle,
si on manque aussi cruellement
de psychologues dans les universités ?
Vous avez parfaitement raison,
on a un sujet de médecine scolaire
et de médecine à l'université.
D'ailleurs, si j'étais complet,
je dirais aussi de médecine au travail.
Et donc, si on veut améliorer la prévention,
on doit ouvrir ce sujet,
parce que ce sont des professions
qui sont devenues moins attractives,
donc on n'a pas assez de professionnels.
Et ils travaillent souvent
dans un cadre très difficile.
Donc, ce que j'ai demandé aux ministres,
c'est un sujet qu'on a ouvert post-Covid,
sur lequel on doit absolument
s'améliorer et investir.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qui est prévu ?
J'insiste, c'est une situation urgente.
On parle d’un jeune sur cinq
qui souffre de troubles dépressifs.
D'ailleurs, les chiffres après le Covid
en matière de tentatives de suicide
chez les jeunes
sont particulièrement importants.
C'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur
au vu du public et des retours qu'on a.
C'est une situation qui est urgente.
Quelles mesures
comptez-vous mettre en place ?
Sur les psychologues,
moi, j'attends le retour d'abord
de ce qu'on a lancé,
puisque, il y a deux ans,
quand vous étiez étudiant,
que vous aviez un problème,
il était mal diagnostiqué.
Une fois qu'il était diagnostiqué,
si vous alliez voir un psychologue,
c'était de votre poche.
On a mis en place un forfait
qui fait que maintenant,
quand vous allez voir un psychologue
et que vous avez un forfait de 10 heures
qui a été donné par votre médecin,
celui de l'université
ou votre médecin traitant,
vous êtes remboursé de ce suivi.
Ça, c'est une avancée qui est liée
à la situation que vous décrivez.
Et donc là, on est en train d'évaluer,
de voir si ça commence à répondre au sujet.
Ça, c'est le premier point.
Visiblement, les chiffres ne sont pas
très encourageants dans ce cadre-là.
Parce qu'on est un an après le Covid,
et les chiffres sont encore pires.
Moi, je n’ai pas les mêmes.
C'est Santé publique France dans mon cas.
Santé publique France regarde le nombre
de professionnels rapporté à la population.
Moi, je vous parle
des nombres de tentatives de suicide.
Mais après, il faut regarder
comment les systèmes qu'on a mis en place
sont efficaces ou pas par rapport à ça.
Donc après, moi, ce que je veux regarder,
et c'est tout le travail qu'on a lancé
avec les professionnels,
c'est de regarder les causes,
et elles sont multifactorielles.
C'est qu'on voit bien qu'on a
un mal-être chez beaucoup de nos jeunes
qui n'est pas lié qu'à une cause.
Tout n'est pas de la santé mentale.
Et là aussi il faut...
Il peut y avoir une anxiété
qu'on n'arrive pas à gérer.
Et donc c'est un ensemble de sujets.
Donc, certains relèvent de la santé.
Et là, il faut pouvoir voir
au mieux un professionnel.
Et ce qu'on doit absolument améliorer,
c'est l'accès à un professionnel de santé
pour nos étudiants.
Et donc ça, c'est tout le défi
de la médecine scolaire et à l'université,
qui est un dossier que j'ai demandé d'ouvrir
aux ministres de l'Éducation nationale
et de l'Enseignement supérieur.
On a des travaux qui vont aboutir
d'ici à la fin de l'année
et qui iront au-delà de ce qu'on a déjà fait
pour investir dans la psychiatrie à l'hôpital
et dans la prise en charge des consultations
auprès de psychologues.
Mais il faut regarder aussi
les causes profondes.
Qu'est-ce qui justifie
qu'on a une génération qui a ce mal-être ?
Tout ne relève pas de la santé mentale.
On a des sujets de santé mentale,
à prendre le plus tôt possible.
Donc je reviens aux diagnostics.
On doit les faire
auprès des enfants et des ados.
Il ne faut pas attendre
que ce soient des étudiants.
La deuxième chose,
c'est la manière de gérer aussi
les anxiétés de la sociétés,
ce qu'on voit poindre.
Et ça, je reprends
ce que beaucoup de psychiatres,
de psychologues évoquent,
c'est une capacité à gérer
les messages anxiogènes
qu'il y a tout au long de la journée,
et donc d'apporter une réponse, un cadre.
Troisième point, c'est la première génération
qui a un rapport,
à la fois à la formation et à la sociabilité,
qui est totalement différent,
qui se fait beaucoup par les réseaux sociaux,
par les écrans,
ce qui change profondément
le rapport à l'autre, à l'anxiété,
le rapport à la capacité à gérer
ses propres frustrations et anxiétés.
On va en reparler après.
Non mais, ce qui m'importe,
ce que je veux vous dire,
c'est que c'est exactement
comme si on disait,
face à des feux de forêt,
à l'issue d'une campagne,
"il faut beaucoup plus de pompiers".
Oui, c'est ce qu'on fait.
Mais il faut se savoir pourquoi
vous avez plus de feux de forêt,
et comment les prévenir.
- Les deux enjeux sont...
- Ils se tiennent.
Mais je ne voudrais pas qu'on regarde
simplement le curatif.
Ce qui est au moins aussi important,
et même plus important,
c'est comment on prévient,
comment on détecte
le plus rapidement possible,
et comment on traite ces causes profondes
du mal-être de beaucoup de nos jeunes.
D'où l'enjeu sur les psychologues
à l'université, qu'on évoquait.
Justement, on va évoquer...
Je fais une parenthèse, mais il faut
diagnostiquer avant l'université.
C'est aussi pour ça que j'insiste
depuis tout à l'heure
sur le diagnostic le plus précoce possible,
et de suivre nos collégiens et lycéens
sur ce plan.
On a beaucoup de sujets
qu'on va pouvoir aborder ce soir.
Celui-ci en est un, et on comprend
qu'il a de multiples facettes,
si je peux me permettre,
parce que ça recouvre d'autres enjeux,
de précarité ou autre.
Un autre sujet qui me paraît essentiel,
et c'est pas...
Moi, en occurrence,
c'est un consensus scientifique dessus,
et c'est des retours,
surtout de nos abonnés, sur le sujet.
On a passé un été important,
avec des records de température,
qui ont entraîné une sécheresse
et des incendies inédits,
en France mais aussi beaucoup en Europe
et dans le reste du monde, au Canada.
Avec ces incendies, on a eu
des corps calcinés en Sicile ou en Grèce
qui ont été découverts
de personnes qui n'ont pas pu fuir.
On a eu évidemment un drame important
en termes de biodiversité dans ce cadre-là.
L'an dernier, Santé publique France
a compté 7 000 décès liés
à la canicule en 2022 en France.
L'urgence, elle est là,
elle est sous nos yeux
et elle tue aujourd'hui.
Quelles nouvelles mesures
comptez-vous mettre en place
pour répondre à cette urgence ?
Alors là aussi, c'est un peu la même chose.
Il y a le curatif et le préventif.
Face à ces urgences, d'abord,
on n'a pas attendu ces dernières années.
La France fait partie des pays qui sont,
parce qu'on a vécu,
rappelez-vous, il y a maintenant 20 ans,
une canicule terrible qui avait touché
les personnes âgées dans notre pays,
en 2003, et qui avait eu
des conséquences absolument terribles.
Donc tout le système s'était
beaucoup après réorganisé.
Et nous avons un des modèles
les plus efficaces
pour lutter contre les feux de forêt.
L'année dernière, on a eu
une année terrible sur les feux de forêt,
ce qui m'a conduit à prendre
des décisions, là aussi de moyens.
On a redéployé plus de moyens
pour lutter contre les feux de forêt.
On l'a européanisé,
on a aussi mis beaucoup plus de moyens
pour prévenir et mieux débroussailler, etc.
Ce qui fait qu'on a eu un été
très bien géré en France,
en lien avec les collectivités locales,
les associations qui débroussaillent, etc.
Et que la France a été un contributeur
de beaucoup de pays européens
et même au Canada,
où on a envoyé nos sapeurs-pompiers.
Mais ça, c'est sur les incendies.
L'enjeu, c'est environnemental.
Non mais, incendies comme canicule,
c'est là et ça va être là pour des années.
Donc là, on traite les conséquences
d'un dérèglement qui est là.
Donc, nos sociétés,
c'est la partie qu'on appelle l'adaptation.
Donc là, la France doit s'organiser
et nous nous organisons.
Donc, on a remis beaucoup de moyens
en termes de sécurité civile,
ça a été une très grosse augmentation
ces dernières années
pour là aussi plus embaucher,
mieux payer, mieux équiper
nos sapeurs-pompiers,
avoir le bon modèle territorial.
La réalité est là.
Je touche du bois, parce qu'on va avoir
des feux de plus en plus tôt
et jusqu'à plus en plus tard.
On résiste bien et on aide nos partenaires.
Sur la canicule, c'est de la même manière.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est en train d'adapter,
et c'est un énorme défi,
nos établissements hospitaliers,
nos EHPAD pour les anciens,
nos écoles, c'est tout un plan que je lance,
et je l'annoncerai demain.
On va faire un plan de rénovation
de nos bâti scolaires
en lien avec les maires.
Et là, le but c'est de rénover
pour le bien-être de nos enfants
et de nos enseignants,
et pour justement se protéger
des conséquences de la canicule
et avoir des bâtiments qui font face
aux situations thermiques actuelles.
Ça, c'est sur des conséquences.
Les causes, c'est le changement climatique.
Alors ça, c'est tout le volet,
puisque vous partez de là...
Nos sociétés doivent faire face
à ce qu'on appelle l'adaptation.
C'est un investissement parce qu'on
va vivre avec ces dérèglements.
Après, les causes profondes,
c'est le réchauffement.
Et donc qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
On doit réussir à moins émettre
et mieux préserver notre biodiversité.
Le combat jumeau, c'est ça.
Et sur ce point, est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles mesures ?
Ce que disent les scientifiques
dans un consensus quasi unanime,
même unanime aujourd'hui,
c'est que ces épisodes
qu'on a vus l'an dernier,
qu'on a vus encore cet été,
vont se reproduire,
vont s'intensifier
avec le changement climatique.
Donc, l'enjeu, il est bien là,
on est d'accord,
c'est l'enjeu de prévenir en luttant
contre le changement climatique.
Avez-vous des mesures de prévues
dans les prochaines semaines
pour prévenir, justement ?
Alors, c'est un ensemble.
L'engagement que j'avais pris
va se doter d'un plan d'ensemble.
D'abord, ces dernières années,
nous sommes revenus dans notre trajectoire.
C'est-à-dire que on a deux fois plus réduit
que durant les cinq années qui ont précédé
nos émissions de CO2.
La France, on est dans quelle situation ?
On est parmi les pays d'Europe
qui ont le moins d'émissions
de CO2 par habitant.
- Parmi les pays développés ?
- Parmi les pays développés.
Sinon, on est parmi les pays
les plus pollueurs au monde.
Alors, dans l'historique,
c'est tout à fait vrai
parce qu'il y a eu
la révolution industrielle.
La France, parce qu'elle a opté
pour le nucléaire
pour produire son énergie,
et que le nucléaire représente
un peu plus de 70 % de la source
de production d'électricité,
eh bien produit son énergie
en utilisant et en émettant beaucoup
moins de carbone que les autres.
Donc je le dis juste par rapport
à nos voisins, on est nous,
avec les pays du nord de l'Europe,
ceux qui produisons
le moins de CO2 par habitant.
Maintenant, quel est notre objectif ?
C'est de le réduire drastiquement
d'ici à 2030
et d'arriver à la neutralité carbone
d'ici 2050.
Donc ça, c'est la planification
écologique qui a été présentée
à l'ensemble des associations
et des ONG à l'été,
qui va être présentée
par la Première ministre
aux forces politiques,
et qu'on va déployer.
Est-ce qu'on est sur le droit chemin ?
Si on fait cette planification, oui,
mais ce n'est pas un chemin spontané.
Comment expliquez-vous
que le Haut Conseil pour le climat
que vous avez créé en 2018
pour justement évaluer votre stratégie
et la stratégie du gouvernement
sur le climat,
eh bien cette même instance,
il y a encore quelques semaines,
fin juin le rapport a été remis
à Élisabeth Borne,
estime que, certes, il y a des évolutions,
mais ces évolutions,
elles vont beaucoup trop lentement
pour ne pas foncer dans le mur ?
C'est sur la base de leur analyse
qu'on va présenter
la planification qui arrive.
Et pour vous représenter les choses...
Jusqu'à 2018, 2013-2018, on a baissé
à un certain rythme, qui était insuffisant.
Ensuite, les cinq ans qui ont suivi,
on a été deux fois plus vite.
Eh bien, les cinq ans qui sont devant nous,
il faut aller encore deux fois plus,
2,5 fois plus vite.
Donc je vous confirme qu'il faut
complètement changer de vitesse
et la nature de nos efforts.
Et donc pour ça, il n'y a pas
une solution unique et miracle :
il faut porter l'effort
dans tous les domaines.
De manière très simple,
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
1, il faut électrifier les pratiques
et donc partout où on utilise du fossile,
il faut passer à l'électrique,
parce qu'on a une chance
que notre électrique,
on ne le produit pas avec du carbone.
Ça n'a pas de sens dans les pays
où on fait de l'électricité avec du charbon.
Et justement, très bon exemple,
sur la question des mesures possibles.
Vous parlez de l'énergie.
Vous parlez des transports.
C'est effectivement un enjeu
de sortir des énergies fossiles
pour aller sur l'électrique, parce que,
comme vous le dites,
on émet peu de CO2 aujourd'hui en France,
parce qu'il y a le nucléaire
qui permet de ne pas produire trop de CO2.
Sur ce sujet, je pense
que c'est un bon exemple de mesures,
et qui sont revenus
dans les questions des abonnés.
Donc, je me permets de la poser.
En Allemagne, depuis le 1er mai,
je pense que vous l'avez suivi,
pour 49 euros par mois,
en plus des métros, des bus, etc,
vous avez accès
à tous les trains en illimité,
tous les trains de région hors TGV,
et pour le reste, tous les trains.
C'est un immense succès.
Il y a plus de 7 millions d'abonnés
à ce service-là.
On voit que c'est quelque chose qui encourage
à délaisser l'avion typiquement,
qui évidemment émet beaucoup plus de CO2,
au profit du train,
de créer des sortes de vacances alternatives,
si on peut dire ça comme ça,
qui forcément sont moins coûteuses
et donc aussi plus intéressantes.
Est-ce que vous comptez
le mettre en place en France ?
Alors oui, mais c'est un ensemble
beaucoup plus large.
Ce n’est pas avec une mesure comme ça
qu'on règle le problème.
C'est un exemple.
Je pense que c'est important
de se donner les masses
pour voir où sont les taux d'effort.
Parce que souvent, dans ce débat,
je le dis,
on s'est perdu sur des micro exemples
et on a perdu la photo d'ensemble
et les vrais points d'effort.
Mais si elle est trop large...
Non, moi, je vais dans le concret sur tout.
Je reste aussi longtemps que vous voulez.
Donc je vais vous dire 1, oui,
j'y suis favorable,
et j'ai demandé au ministre des Transports
de lancer,
avec les régions qui sont prêtes à le faire,
le même dispositif.
La réalité chez nous,
c'est que c'est les régions
qui ont la tarification de leurs billets.
Toutes les régions qui sont prêtes
à le faire avec l'État, banco.
Il y a un tour de table avec les régions,
et on aura un service similaire
dans les prochains mois.
Le ministre des Transports
et la Première Ministre portent cette idée.
2, la Première Ministre l'a annoncé,
on met en place un pass train
pour tous les jeunes
qui se mettent au service national
universel de service civique,
pour pouvoir utiliser le train
beaucoup plus simplement.
Et 3, on a surtout acté cette décision,
partout où on avait des lignes de TGV,
de faciliter le transfert modal
et de plutôt passer à l'avion vers le train
en fermant certaines lignes d'aviation.
Si on regarde, il y a des trucs
très concrets qu'on va faire.
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on va moins émettre
de CO2 et préserver la biodiversité ?
Parce que je ne veux pas
qu'on perde de vue la biodiversité
qui est aussi importante, parce que
les forêts sont des puits de carbone
et des trésors de biodiversité,
comme nos océans.
Ce sont deux grands combats pour nous,
qu'on porte au national et à l'international.
Nous, on doit donner le coup d'accélérateur
sur la rénovation thermique des bâtiments.
On a fait un million de rénovations
thermiques et donc là, dans la planification,
on va lancer de nouveaux instruments
et aider à accélérer
et intensifier cet effort
sur la rénovation thermique.
Ça veut dire encourager ceux qui peuvent
à faire des travaux.
Sous quelle forme ?
C'est simplifier les aides
et c'est les accroître.
Et la deuxième chose,
c'est mettre des contraintes
à certains propriétaires
qui ont des logements
qui ne sont plus du tout en état,
où il y a énormément
de gaspillage énergétique,
parce que c'est ni écologique ni juste :
les gens qui y vivent dépensent beaucoup.
Et donc, au moment où ils les vendent
ou qu'ils changent de locataires,
de devoir faire les travaux.
Donc là, il y a tout un travail
sur le logement qui est à faire,
avec là aussi des innovations
qui permettent de le faire
de manière beaucoup moins coûteuse qu'avant.
Deuxième point,
c'est développer massivement,
et ça j'y reviendrai, les pompes à chaleur,
qui sont un instrument qui,
à côté de l'électrification,
de manière concrète...
Donc, on veut développer un système
et une filière française de pompes à chaleur,
déployer leur mise en œuvre,
parce que ça permet justement
de réduire la consommation
et de réduire les émissions de CO2.
3, c'est les transports, et les transports,
vous l'avez très bien dit,
le but est d'aller vers plus
de transports collectifs,
en particulier dans les zones urbaines.
Et dans quelques semaines, je présenterai
la carte des projets qu'on a retenus,
c'est les fameux RER Métropolitains.
C'est de se dire, dans nos métropoles,
certaines ont commencé,
d'autres sont plus en retard.
On met le paquet pour investir
et pour déployer justement
des réseaux électriques,
parfois avec des connexions hydrogène,
pour justement avoir des connexions
et faciliter
l'abandon du véhicule individuel,
aller vers le collectif,
avoir une politique préférentielle
en termes de tarification
et inciter tous les habitants
à se déplacer par ces solutions.
Une question très claire sur ce point-là,
sur la question des transports.
Vous le savez, évidemment, sur les voitures,
par exemple, on a des bonus, des malus.
De la même façon aujourd'hui
sur les transports en commun,
si on peut utiliser le terme
de transports en commun,
les trains et l'avion,
le ressenti aujourd'hui,
et pas qu'un ressenti,
c'est que sur certaines destinations,
le train coûte plus cher que l'avion.
En plus de ça, souvent il est plus long.
Ça peut être plus confortable
de partir depuis le centre-ville,
mais ça coûte plus cher souvent
et c'est plus long.
Et je parle de bonus/malus,
parce qu'il y a aussi un ressenti
que l'avion finalement est un mode
de transport épargné par rapport au train.
C'est-à-dire que typiquement, l'avion,
le kérosène n'est pas taxé.
Ça a été appliqué dans d'autres pays,
certains ont appliqué une taxation
sur le kérosène, sur les vols nationaux.
Parce que c'est autorisé
sur les vols nationaux.
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il n'y a pas
de taxation sur le kérosène
alors qu'on sait que l'avion est infiniment
plus polluant que le train ?
La France est un des pays
qui taxe le plus son aviation.
Et sur le kérosène ?
Non, mais la vérité,
c'est qu'on veut avoir un système qui reste.
On peut le bouger si on le bouge au moins
à l'échelle européenne, voire internationale.
La deuxième chose, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
nous, on crée toutes les incitations,
on a fermé certaines lignes.
Les moins de 2 h 30, il me semble.
Exactement. Donc on évolue.
Troisième chose, on a mis en place
la taxe sur les billets d'avion
pour financer le développement,
donc on taxe justement nos acteurs.
On va taxer aussi
les concessions aéroportuaires,
ça va retomber sur les compagnies.
Donc ce serait faux de dire que, aujourd'hui,
il y a un avantage fiscal
pour les acteurs de l'aviation.
Et même, la France taxe plus
que beaucoup d'autres voisins son aviation.
Derrière ça...
Comment on termine avec un billet de train
beaucoup plus cher qu'un billet d'avion ?
Ça peut se comprendre quand on est...
Le billet d'avion, s'il n'y avait
qu'un seul acteur, il serait aussi cher.
Ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'on a eu
des économies très différentes,
qu'on a des acteurs low-cost
qui sont rentrés
dans le système de l'aviation
et qui sont venus casser les prix.
Mais l'État peut réguler,
Non mais on régule,
mais on est une économie ouverte.
Mais on peut réguler quand même.
Et que du côté du transport ferroviaire,
il n'y avait ni réforme ni ouverture.
Là, une petite révolution ferroviaire
est en train de se faire.
D'abord, on a changé le système
ferroviaire, on l'a modernisé.
C'est la réforme de 2018.
Il y a eu des grèves,
j'ai eu beaucoup de critiques.
Mais tous les gens qui disent
"il faut aller vers le ferroviaire",
c'est beaucoup qui n'ont jamais eu
le courage de réformer le système.
Le système ferroviaire,
pourquoi c'était cher ?
Parce qu'on ne faisait pas de réforme,
qu'on avait un système de retraite
qui n'était plus soutenable,
qu'on avait un système
qui n'était pas efficace.
Donc, on ne peut pas dire d'un côté,
"je défends un système inefficace,
mais je suis pour l'écologie".
Non. Moi, je suis cohérent.
Ce n'est pas mon cas.
Non, mais je lis beaucoup de commentaires.
C'est une question qui revient souvent.
Mais je dis juste, moi, je suis cohérent.
Le système, l'aviation,
il y a un acteur français qui est Air France,
il a été concurrencé
par beaucoup de low-cost,
ce qui crée la situation que vous évoquez.
On a régulé jusqu'à un certain point
et la France a plus taxé que ses voisins
les billets d'avion.
Maintenant, il y a ce différentiel,
parce que du côté du ferroviaire,
il y avait moins de concurrence
et un acteur qui n'était pas assez efficace.
On a fait la réforme de la SNCF.
On est plus efficace.
On a des cheminots formidablement
engagés dans cette transition.
On va aller vers du mieux en mieux.
On investit sur les infrastructures.
Pourquoi ça marchait moins bien
et c'était plus cher ?
Parce que pendant des décennies,
on avait sous-investi
sur les infrastructures ferroviaires.
Depuis 2018, on réinvesti massivement
en parallèle.
On a encore du boulot là-dessus.
C'est la responsabilité de l'État,
pas des régions.
À côté de ça, on veut unifier,
avoir une politique tarifaire mieux-disante.
C'est ce qu'on va faire avec les régions
en allant vers un pass à tarif unifié.
Et maintenant, qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
justement derrière,
si on veut être cohérents ?
C'est permettre à d'autres acteurs...
Certaines lignes sont ouvertes
à d'autres acteurs européens
qui sont parfois moins chers,
qui arrivent sur notre réseau
et rendent le train attractif.
Je voudrais juste ajouter un point.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
en parallèle de tout ça ?
Il y a une responsabilité.
Beaucoup se disent
"je préfère prendre le train".
À mesure qu'on fait ces réformes,
ça se rapproche.
Ceux qui en ont le moyen.
Oui, mais on rapproche
de plus en plus.
Mais en parallèle,
il faut décarboner l'aviation,
parce qu'on prendra toujours des avions.
Et objectivement en plus, en France...
Est-ce qu'on prendra forcément
autant l'avion ?
Nous, en France,
on produit beaucoup d'avions.
Et je serais un drôle de président
à vous dire ça,
alors que nous sommes
un des champions de l'aéronautique
et que nous produisons, je crois, environ...
Enfin une bonne partie de la flotte
internationale, d'un point non négligeable.
Donc on a des grands champions
et qu'on a des emplois partout en France.
- Mais c'est...
- Non mais attendez.
Il y a une question qui est très simple
et qui me paraît centrale dans ce sujet,
c'est que j'entends que l'aviation
est un élément important en France.
Il faudrait des solutions écologiques,
je vais y venir.
Mais l'enjeu, est-ce que réellement,
pour des raisons économiques,
on doit continuer à encourager
une industrie qui, de fait,
pollue infiniment plus que d'autres
modes de transport ?
- Il faut la décarboner.
- Mais comment ?
Nous, dans notre usage.
qu'est-ce qu'on va tous faire ?
Et c'est ça, la transition.
1, on va se poser des questions
qu'on ne se posait pas avant.
Est-ce que j'ai vraiment besoin de faire ça ?
C'est les comportements qu'on appelle
de sobriété ou d'économie d'énergie.
Il n'y a de toutes façons pas de transition
s'il n'y a pas ce premier bloc, clair.
Deuxième point, dans la transition,
on doit là aussi décarboner.
Et donc, la bataille, c'est,
dans cette industrie,
et la France va le faire dans d'autres
industries où elle est championne,
on décarboner,
donc on investit beaucoup d'argent.
Donc comment on fait pour que l'avion
pollue moins ?
À court terme, on fait de l'innovation
et on allège justement le poids des avions.
On change la motorisation.
C'est ce qu'on fait
avec nos grands acteurs, comme Safran.
Et on change la nature des carburants.
C'est très concret ce que je dis,
c'est maintenant.
Oui, mais ce que disent
les scientifiques aujourd'hui,
et je me permet donc de le dire,
ce que disent les scientifiques aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'on ne peut pas attendre
une innovation de l'aviation
pour s'en sortir.
Je ne suis pas en train de vous dire...
Le schéma, il est là, hein.
Ce que je suis en train de vous dire,
ce n'est pas une innovation.
L'enjeu, c'est qu'on réduise nos courbes.
Je relaye ce que disent les scientifiques,
le rapport du GIEC,
le Haut Conseil sur le climat,
c'est qu'il y a peut-être une modernisation
qui est possible de l'aviation,
avec des projets qui sont en cours.
Pour autant, ce que disent l'intégralité
des scientifiques sur le sujet,
c'est que ça ne suffit pas
et qu'il faut baisser progressivement
l'utilisation de l'aviation.
Mais ce que je veux vous dire,
c'est qu'on peut parler après de la planète.
Là, je suis sur la France.
Non, mais on peut agir en France.
Mais c'est ce qu'on fait,
et on agit massivement.
On est sur notre trajectoire
et on va tenir nos objectifs
grâce à cette planification.
Mais c'est totalement faux de dire
si nous, on faisait ça simplement
en franco-français,
si les autres ne le font pas.
Donc, c'est un effort mondial.
Mais nous, qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
Je reviens à l'industrie aéronautique.
Si on veut réduire les émissions,
1, il faut des avions plus légers.
2, il faut des moteurs
qui consomment moins à performances égales
ou qui se transforment pour moins émettre.
C'est les moteurs
qu'on développe aujourd'hui.
3, il faut changer de carburant.
Et donc on est en train progressivement
de sortir du kérosène.
Et entre maintenant et 2030,
quel est notre objectif ?
C'est d'intégrer progressivement
ce qu'on appelle les SAF,
qui sont nos carburants durables
qu'on met dans les avions,
avec le kérosène,
et de passer d'ici à 2030 à 50 % de SAF.
4, ensuite c'est passer
à l'avion hydrogène et électrique.
Et donc oui, on est en train
de faire ces innovations,
et ça, c'est du post-2030.
Donc il y a une courbe sur l'aviation.
Il y a un enjeu de réduction
de l'utilisation-même de l'avion.
On passe au sujet suivant,
autrement on est là...
Non, mais c'est hyper important.
Mais ce que je dis,
c'est que la France a un plan.
Ce plan, on l'a présenté début juillet.
Il va être présenté aux forces politiques,
et je vous le présenterai bientôt.
Ce plan touche tous les secteurs.
Et c'est faux de dire "si on se fait très mal
sur un secteur, on va y arriver seul".
La France, c'est 1 % des émissions mondiales.
On va faire notre part.
Et il se trouve que nous
qui émettons moins de CO2 par habitant
que beaucoup d'autres pays européens,
on tient notre part.
Mais on ne remplit pas les objectifs
que les scientifiques ont établis
pour s'en sortir.
- À date, on les remplit.
- On est en retard.
Non, les scientifiques nous disent :
"Si vous voulez remplir sur les cinq années
à venir, vous devez faire..."
- "2,5 fois plus"
- C'est ce que je vous dis.
Je suis hyper transparent,
vous l'avez dit vous-même,
j'ai créé une instance pour évaluer.
Qui dit que c'est insuffisant,
Parce qu'elle nous dit
"si vous voulez réussir en 2030".
C'est pour ça
que je me fatigue à faire un plan, là.
Je ne dis pas qu'on continue pareil.
Mais donc, c'est le logement, c'est le train,
c'est aller vers plus de véhicules
hybrides et électriques,
donc c'est la révolution de la voiture,
c'est l'avion.
Et là où je suis d'accord avec vous,
il faut un peu réduire la consommation,
il faut beaucoup moderniser.
Donc c'est un ensemble, et pas simplement
dire on va tous arrêter de prendre l'avion.
D'autres que je respecte sont là-dessus.
Pas moi.
C'est décarboner notre industrie.
On sait que l'industrie,
c'est une part non négligeable des émissions.
On en a parlé un peu pour l'aviation,
mais il y a les ciments, etc.
Là, on a lancé un très grand plan
et on a dit :
"Les principaux sites émetteurs,
eh bien on décarboner,
et on les fait passer du gaz ou du charbon
à l'hydrogène, etc."
Et on y va.
Je me permets de passer,
parce qu'on a passé la moitié de l'interview.
Il reste plusieurs thématiques à aborder.
Je voudrais juste dézoomer
deux secondes cette affaire.
Rapidement, pour qu'on puisse
aborder d'autres sujets.
C'est que nous, on se bat.
Et je crois
que c'est un combat générationnel,
et c'est notre responsabilité.
Et je vous le dis,
on sera au rendez-vous de nos résultats.
Et ça va demander
un effort à tout le monde.
Mais il faut que chacun comprenne
l'effort que fait l'autre.
Donc personne ne sera exempt
de la transition.
La France, c'est à peu près
1 % des émissions.
Nous, on fera notre effort,
si on veut que la planète s'en sorte.
Plus que ça si on prend
en compte les importations.
Il faut qu'on passe au sujet suivant.
Mais ce qui est important de comprendre,
c'est où est le cœur
de la bataille à l'international.
Parce qu'on fait partie
des pays leaders sur ce sujet.
Le cœur de la bataille, c'est quoi ?
La sortie du charbon.
La sortie du pétrole.
Si on arrive à ce que les grands émergents
sortent du charbon,
une bonne partie
de la bagarre est gagnée.
Donc moi, j'ai un objectif,
et je reprends les termes du Haut Conseil
pour le climat et sa présidente :
Charbon 2030, Pétrole 2040-2045.
Si on arrive, et nous, on va se mettre
sur cet agenda d'ici à la fin de l'année,
à aller sur cet objectif...
Nous on y arrivera pour le charbon,
grâce justement au renouvelable
et au nucléaire.
Et on va se mettre en place
pour le faire sur le pétrole,
ce qui est un très gros effort.
On est en retard.
Je me permets d'avancer.
C'est hyper important.
Il ne faut pas perdre de vue
qu'on a cet immense objectif charbon/pétrole
pour les décennies qui viennent,
et qu'on va le porter à l'international,
et que la France est leader
sur l'agenda forêts et océans.
On a lancé le One Forest Summit
qui est clé pour la biodiversité,
et pour protéger les forêts primaires.
Tout ce que je suis en train de dire
pour la France ne vaut pas
si on laisse déforester l'Amazonie
ou la forêt d'Asie du Sud-Est.
Je me permets vraiment d'avancer
parce que je vois que le temps file.
J'ai passé beaucoup plus de temps que prévu
sur ce sujet-là.
En même temps, il me paraît essentiel.
Il faut qu'on parle de cette école.
C'est pour ça.
On a passé beaucoup de temps
sur ce sujet d'environnement,
qui est un sujet important.
Sur la rentrée,
on rentre sur la question de la rentrée.
Effectivement, on est le lundi 4 septembre,
jour de rentrée.
Mais avant même de parler de la rentrée,
on va parler plus de rythmes scolaires
et donc de la question des vacances,
pendant un instant.
En effet, il y a eu un certain nombre
de déclarations qui ont été faites
ces derniers jours
et ces derniers mois.
Un sujet important,
c'est la question des vacances d'été.
Vous avez évoqué une idée
d'une refonte des vacances d'été.
Est-ce que les prochaines vacances d'été,
d'ici la fin de votre quinquennat,
seront plus courtes que celles
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui ?
D'abord, ça, ça doit se concerter.
Mais je souhaite qu'on ouvre
cette question des vacances,
ou plutôt du temps scolaire dans l'année.
L'école, on y reviendra,
mais c'est quoi la mission de l'école ?
C'est hyper important.
Transmettre des savoirs.
Transmettre un esprit critique.
Des valeurs.
Faire des républicains.
Et donner la confiance.
Et acquérir ce faisant.
Donc à mes yeux aussi faire du sport,
des activités artistiques, etc.
La France, on a des programmes
plutôt chargés par rapport aux voisins,
mais je ne compte pas les alléger
parce qu'on veut remettre
plus de fondamentaux et mieux les évaluer.
Parce qu'aujourd'hui, on a trop d'enfants
qui arrivent en CM2,
qui ne savent pas assez
lire, écrire, compter.
Du coup, en 6ème, ils se perdent.
C'est là qu'on a le décrochage scolaire.
Est-ce qu'on a les meilleures conditions
pour apprendre ?
La réalité, c'est non.
Parce qu'en fait, on concentre
le temps scolaire sur quelques jours
On peut faire du 8h-18h en une journée.
Et ça fait qu'on a moins de sport,
d'activités artistiques.
Or, c'est très bon pour le développement,
pour la confiance en soi,
et on apprend mieux.
Et à l'inverse, on a des vacances,
même par rapport...
Vous êtes beaucoup plus jeune.
Quand j'étais à l'école, on n'avait pas
deux semaines à la Toussaint
ou à Pâques.
On a accru ces vacances intercalaires
et on a des vacances d'été
beaucoup plus longues que les copains,
et surtout plus longues que ce qu'on dit.
Parce que la vérité,
c'est comme le brevet des collèges
et le bac sont organisés souvent
dans l'établissement...
Courant juin, et pas début juillet.
Mi-juin, ça devient plus calme.
Que ceux qui ont vraiment le collège
ou le lycée complet lèvent le doigt.
Je peux plaider coupable pour ça à l'époque.
Mais...
Moi, qu'est-ce que je dis ?
Je veux que nos enfants
et nos adolescents apprennent mieux.
Donc, on doit ouvrir ce sujet.
Donc, j'ai dit aux ministres,
et ce n'est pas qu'un sujet vacances.
C'est une question de rythme
de la vie étudiante.
Premier sujet et immense sujet
que je veux dire,
pour les parents et les jeunes.
Le sujet remplacement.
On va en parler
On y reviendra alors.
Donc il faut repenser
les vacances et le temps
pour pouvoir avoir plus de temps
de sport, de culture, de repos
et de devoirs dans l'année.
Quelle forme ça peut prendre ?
On a des modèles en Allemagne,
par exemple, où effectivement les...
C'est des modèles attractifs.
C'est un modèle
que vous aimeriez voir en France,
quasiment des demi-journées ?
C'est un système qui doit se parler,
se discuter au plus près du terrain.
Mais je pense qu'il faut ouvrir ce sujet.
Ça ne doit pas être un tabou.
Que le sujet des vacances est un sujet,
pour apprendre mieux, qui doit être ouvert,
que c'est ce qui permet aussi
à nos enseignants d'avoir moins de stress.
Il faut mesurer que les enseignants...
Il y a beaucoup de caricatures de faites.
Préparer les cours, corriger les copies,
c'est beaucoup de travail.
Les enseignants ne travaillent pas
que devant les élèves,
et donc ça leur prend aussi
beaucoup de temps.
Si on leur permettait de mieux travailler
dans l'année, ce serait mieux.
Mais surtout, les élèves
apprendraient mieux si on repensait ça.
Est-ce que...
On parlait d'inégalités.
Les grandes vacances,
c'est la pire des inégalités.
Parce que quand vous êtes d'une famille
qui vous fait faire des devoirs de vacances,
qui a une bibliothèque à la maison,
qui vous fait faire du sport,
qui vous envoie en voyage linguistique
à l'étranger,
vous revenez en septembre,
vous êtes super prêt.
Quand vous êtes d'une famille pauvre
qui ne peut pas partir en vacances,
dans un quartier où il n'y a pas
d'infrastructures sportives,
vous revenez,
vous êtes généralement crevé,
vous avez passé des mauvaises vacances
et vous avez désappris.
Et ce qui fait que vous avez...
On regarde, ça a été mesuré.
Vous me parlez d'études, à juste titre.
Vous portez des faits.
Moi aussi.
Un jeune d'un quartier populaire
revient au 1er septembre,
il n'a pas son niveau du 1er juillet.
Il a généralement son niveau
de fin mai, mi-mai.
C'est la pire des injustices.
C'est aussi pour ça que je dis,
quand on a des évaluations difficiles,
il faut peut-être pouvoir rentrer
un peu plus tôt.
Très rapidement, pour comprendre un peu
votre vision sur le sujet.
J'entends que ce n'est pas
un sujet seulement de vacances.
Il y a aussi les cours.
C'est un sujet de réorganisation
du temps scolaire
pour faire en sorte d'avoir
des journées qui sont différentes.
Pour visualiser un peu
ce que vous imaginez,
je sais que c'est des concertations,
mais est-ce que vous avez
un modèle en tête ?
C'est quoi dans l'idéal, selon vous,
la journée d'un jeune
au collège ou au lycée ?
C'est le matin
jusqu'au début d'après-midi en cours
et l'après-midi, culture ou sport ?
Je ne veux pas faire de modèle unique.
Le modèle que je vois,
c'est un modèle où chaque élève
à l'école primaire,
ce qu'on a mis en place, fait au moins
une demi-heure de sport par jour.
Moi, j'espère demain une heure.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait en sorte
d'y arriver ?
Parce qu'une heure,
dans le cadre des cours ou en dehors...
Mais honnêtement,
si on fait ce que je suis en train de dire,
on a largement la place.
Et je pense que, ce faisant,
qu'est-ce qu'on apprend avec le sport ?
C'est pour ça que j'y crois.
Là, on a mis la demi-heure,
donc demi-heure en primaire,
on fait 2 heures de plus au collège
en utilisant le temps périscolaire,
et on fait le test en 6ème,
l'évaluation sportive, condition sportive.
Pourquoi j'y crois à fond ?
1, c'est quand on fait du sport,
on est bien.
2, c'est un formidable instrument
pour mieux apprendre.
Parce que quand on est un élève dissipé,
un peu hyperactif,
quand on n'aime pas l'école,
on arrive le matin,
bon courage pour commencer
les maths à 8h ou 8h30.
Les Finlandais l'ont fait très bien.
Je regarde ce qui marche ailleurs.
Il y a des endroits, les élèves sont calmes,
pas besoin de faire de sport le matin,
ils vont le faire l'après-midi.
D'autres, vous leur faites faire 30 min
de balle au prisonnier ou de rugby,
puisqu'on a la Coupe du monde
qui commence dans la semaine,
je peux vous dire qu'ils apprendront
les maths l'heure d'après vachement mieux.
Donc le sport, ça aide à mieux apprendre.
3, c'est un instrument de santé.
On parlait justement de prévenir.
Le sport, c'est un instrument de santé,
ça prévient l'obésité.
Avec la santé mentale,
vous avez commencé par là.
C'était un formidable sujet,
et on est encore très loin d'y répondre.
Vous l'avez bien mesuré,
et je mesure le défi.
Un autre immense problème
de santé publique
pour nos ados et nos jeunes, c'est l'obésité.
Nos jeunes, c'est aussi la conséquence
des écrans, par rapport à il y a 20 ans,
sont malheureusement
de plus en plus obèses.
C'est le sport, la politique de prévention.
Et ça permet justement
d'éviter des tas de maladies.
Et plutôt que se dire dans 10 ans,
quand votre successeur interrogera le mien...
- Je serai peut-être encore là.
- Vous oui, moi non.
Donc vous avez raison de me dire ça.
Vous interrogez mon successeur
et vous direz :
"Pourquoi vous n'avez
pas assez de médecins
pour encadrer l'obésité
ou le diabète des jeunes ?"
J'espère qu'il pourra vous dire
"on a moins d'obèses".
Donc ça c'est le sport
et puis ça donne un cadre.
Il y a des tas de jeunes
qui n'ont pas assez de cadre.
Le sport en donne un.
Donc, comment je vois ?
Pour moi, c'est très flexible, le système.
Il faut qu'il y ait...
Je voudrais qu'il y ait à terme
1 heure de sport par jour en primaire.
Au moins autant en collège.
Je voudrais qu'on ait des jeunes
qui aient la possibilité
d'avoir une pratique culturelle, tous,
quelques heures par semaine.
Le Pass Culture avait été annoncé.
Le Pass Culture est entendu dès la 6ème,
mais que l'éducation artistique et culturelle
entre dès l'école primaire
et que ce ne soient pas
des activités périscolaires
qui dépendent du choix de la famille.
Même si les mairies font
un formidable boulot sur ce sujet
et qu'on a des conservatoires,
des écoles de danse,
de spectacle et d'art vivant
partout en France.
C'est notre force.
Mais que ce soit dans l'école
et que, ce faisant,
on ait un temps scolaire
qui soit plus souple,
et qui, parce qu'on n'a plus de semaines
d'école, de collège et de lycée dans l'année,
on puisse y intégrer du sport,
de l'éducation artistique et culturelle
et le temps de devoirs
et d'accompagnement.
Ce sera une école où on apprend mieux
et qui est plus juste.
Sur la question de l'école,
on a parlé du temps scolaire,
et on entend votre vision sur le sujet.
On verra quelle forme ça peut prendre
dans les prochaines années, éventuellement.
Un autre sujet
qui est beaucoup revenu aujourd'hui.
On ne va pas passer
énormément de temps dessus,
mais ça me paraît important d'y revenir.
C'est la question de l'abaya,
qui est donc interdite dans les écoles
depuis la rentrée.
Ça a été confirmé par le ministre
de l'Éducation nationale, Gabriel Attal.
C'est un sujet qui concerne
quelques centaines d'établissements
sur plus de 59 000 établissements
aujourd'hui.
Et une question qui est beaucoup revenue
dans les commentaires
lorsque j'ai annoncé l'interview hier,
c'est la question de savoir,
au-delà du débat sur l'interdiction,
le choix d'annoncer une telle chose
au journal de 20h,
alors qu'on est une veille de rentrée
qui a énormément d'enjeu,
on a commencé à en voir
quelques-uns qui sont présents.
Le choix d'en faire une telle annonce,
quand on sait que ça va provoquer
autant de débats,
autant de réactions,
et peut-être masquer d'autres sujets
qui concernent aussi
beaucoup de monde.
C'est évidemment un sujet, mais l'enjeu
c'était la façon dont ça s'est...
Vous avez raison.
Mais qui de l'œuf ou la poule ?
Il faut y répondre clairement.
Ça peut être différemment
qu'en faisant un JT de 20h.
On sait quand on fait ça, en général,
ce que ça provoque.
Le ministre, au 20 h,
il a été clair, et je l'en félicite.
Je vais vous dire, en France,
l'école, elle est
gratuite, laïque et obligatoire.
Laïque, ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire que nos enfants,
on ne veut pas savoir d'où ils viennent,
ce qu'ils pensent.
C'est un élément de justice,
parce que ce sont des républicains
et des citoyens qu'on forme.
Et donc, de la maternelle
jusqu'au baccalauréat,
l'école est laïque,
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas la place
pour les signes religieux.
Et c'est très important.
Et vous avez...
Ça a été vécu
comme une forme de stigmatisation,
au-delà du débat
sur le caractère religieux de la tenue.
Vous me connaissez, je ne suis pas...
Je ne stigmatise personne,
ce ne sont pas des sujets.
sur lesquels je montre du doigt.
Je suis pour
tous les enfants de la République.
C'est la façon dont ça a été ressenti.
Qui stigmatise ?
Les gens qui poussent la bagarre.
Ça peut être un choix aussi de certains.
Mais non,
parce que c'est un choix religieux,
qui convie quelque chose qui est
le fait de dire "moi, je suis différent,
et je viens dans cette école comme ça".
Je le regrette.
Je pense que ça a été très bien fait
par les directeurs d'établissement
et les enseignants ce matin.
Il faut discuter, il faut expliquer.
Mais je pense que c'est très important,
parce que l'école doit rester ce lieu neutre.
Je ne connais pas votre religion,
ni vous la mienne.
Quand on est étudiant,
on peut remettre un signe religieux,
parce que les consciences sont forgées.
Mais c'est très important.
Et c'est pour ça que moi,
j'ai assumé en 2020
de fermer des écoles qui sortaient
du système scolaire des enfants
et qui en quelque sorte
les ramenaient à leur condition.
On avait des écoles
qui étaient très stigmatisantes,
et qui sortaient bien souvent des fillettes
de notre système scolaire.
On les a fermées.
Tout le monde doit être
dans le système scolaire
public, privé, sous contrat ou non.
Mais on doit respecter,
dans l'école publique,
ce principe qui est important de laïcité.
- Au-delà de cette question de la valeur...
- Dans le respect et la bienveillance.
1, je pense que le ministre
a eu raison d'être clair.
Parce qu'on ne peut pas faire
comme si on vivait dans un pays
où la question était apaisée.
Parce que si on n'est pas clair
au niveau national,
ce sont les enseignants
et les directeurs d'établissement
qui sont renvoyés
avec la pression sur le terrain.
Donc il faut les protéger,
parce que sinon on dit pas de vagues
et on laisse s'installer des défis
à la laïcité, et la loi n'est pas respectée.
Dans les enjeux...
Ensuite, 2, moi, je pense
que ce n'est pas le sujet le plus important.
C'est un sujet où il faut être
intraitable et clair, et on le sera.
Maintenant, il faut que tout le monde
s'y range et que ce soit respecté.
Il faut que les familles
qui voulaient mettre l'abaya pour leur fille
ou les jeunes filles qui voulaient la mettre
comprennent ce pourquoi on le fait.
C'est respectueux, c'est bienveillant,
c'est la laïcité.
Là-dessus...
On ne les empêche pas de croire,
mais dans l'école, ça n'a pas de place.
Le cœur de la bataille,
c'est comment on apprend mieux,
on transmet les valeurs.
Et très rapidement là-dessus,
parce que le débat est très présent.
Chaque année, la question
des vêtements revient à la rentrée.
Cette année, c'est l'abaya.
L'an dernier, c'était le crop top,
donc un t-shirt court.
Vous aviez déclaré au magazine Elle,
je cite,
que "tout ce qui vous renvoie à une identité,
une volonté de choquer ou d'exister
n'a pas sa place à l'école".
C'est quasi systématiquement la tenue
des femmes qui revient sur ces débats.
Qu'est-ce que c'est, dans ce cas,
Une bonne tenue pour aller à l'école ?
Ce n'est pas le président de la République
qui le dit.
Il y a des règles fixées
par le gouvernement.
Je réagissais à un problème de société.
Sur la laïcité,
c'est le président de la République
qui en est le garant, parce que nous sommes
une république laïque.
Après, les chefs d'établissements
ont cette possibilité.
Dans chaque établissement,
il y a des règlements,
et donc il faut s'y conformer,
et donc je renvoie...
- On voit bien qu'il y a des zones...
- Mais non...
Il y a des déclarations.
Mais c'est pour ça que je pense
que c'est une bonne chose
que ce soit au niveau de l'établissement.
Vous avez des établissements,
les parents y mettent leurs enfants,
ils se conforment aux règles.
Là, c'est le gouvernement qui a dit.
Parce que les chefs d'établissement,
à juste titre,
ont trouvé la pression trop grosse.
On a des parents qui nous défient,
on a des gens qui testent la laïcité.
Il ne faut pas se tromper.
Nous vivons dans notre société aussi
avec une minorité de gens qui,
détournant une religion,
viennent défier la République et la laïcité.
Et pardon,
mais ça a parfois donné le pire.
On ne peut pas faire
comme si il n'y avait pas eu
l'attaque terroriste et l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty.
Et ça s'est fait...
Là, on parle de l'abaya.
Mais je ne fais aucun...
Mais je dis juste ce système est là.
Et ça s'est fait parce qu'un enseignant
apprenait la laïcité dans son cours,
et qu'il y a eu cet emballement
avec les réseaux sociaux,
et des gens qui ont commis le pire.
On ne va pas entrer dans ce débat.
Mais est-ce que l'abaya est réellement...
La façon dont vous le voyez ici,
c'est un parallèle qui, je pense,
peut faire débat.
Je ne fais aucun parallèle, moi.
Le parallèle entre l'abaya
et l'assassinat de Samuel Paty.
Je ne fais pas un parallèle.
Je vous dis juste que la question
de la laïcité dans notre école
est une question profonde.
Je ne l'ai pas mise en avant
en vous parlant de l'école.
Je pense que l'école est un sujet
éminemment important
pour transmettre les savoirs.
Nos enseignants apprennent
aussi des valeurs, dont la laïcité.
Et le cadre, c'est la laïcité.
Et que je n'en fais pas, moi,
un principe que je brandis.
Je dis juste
vous avez une minorité de gens.
Vous l'avez dit, environ 500 établissements
sont les plus soumis à cette pression.
Mais que si le ministre
de l'Éducation nationale,
et moi en répondant
à votre question aujourd'hui,
n'est pas clair et courageux,
le risque, c'est que s'installe
l'impression en France
qu'en quelque sorte nous abandonnons
les professeurs aux avant-postes
et que c'est eux
qui sont en charge de ça.
Et vous avez des professeurs qui,
quand ils enseignent la laïcité,
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes,
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière ?
La possibilité,
le droit de caricature et autres.
Se font alors attaquer jusqu'au pire.
Et je vous dis juste,
je vous rappelle juste,
que dans mon premier quinquennat,
il y a peu,
c'est arrivé et le pire est arrivé,
donc ça existe.
Il y a des gens capables du pire
dans notre pays.
Donc on ne doit rien céder.
Il ne faut pas généraliser.
On a des millions de gens
qui veulent vivre en paix.
Moi, je suis pour la bienveillance
et la tranquillité.
Donc le ministre
a eu raison d'être claire.
On doit être intraitable,
expliquer, concerter,
mais on ne doit pas
cacher la poussière sous le tapis.
Un dernier sujet
sur la question du vêtement.
Il y a 1 000 autres sujets à aller évoquer,
donc on va essayer d'avancer.
Ce sont des sujets importants,
qui méritent aussi qu'on prenne le temps.
On en a parlé ici.
Sur la question du vêtement,
certains proposent le retour de l'uniforme,
ça ne vous aura pas échappé.
Gabriel Attal,
le ministre de l'Éducation nationale,
est favorable à des expérimentations.
Il a d'ailleurs déclaré ce matin sur RTL
qu'il allait mettre en place
des expérimentations
à l'automne, il me semble,
donc on suivra tout ça.
En 2017, vous aviez déclaré
réfléchir à cette question.
Vous n'aviez pas de position arrêtée
sur la question de l'uniforme.
Aujourd'hui,
est-ce que vous avez évolué ?
Quelle est votre position aujourd'hui
sur le port de l'uniforme à l'école ?
Je suis pour être...
Comme vous l'avez dit,
ça prend des proportions folles.
Bon, moi j'étais plutôt pour que
chaque établissement gère la chose.
Donc je suis plutôt
pour qu'on expérimente.
Alors il y a l'uniforme,
il y a aussi la tenue unique,
sans avoir un uniforme.
On peut dire vous vous mettez
en jean, t-shirt et veste.
Je vous regarde.
Ce n'est pas un uniforme.
Je n'aurais pas grand-chose à faire.
Je suis plus étudiant, en plus.
Je veux dire, on peut avoir des choses
beaucoup plus acceptables
pour les adolescents.
La question de la tenue unique,
qui à mon avis est plus acceptable,
peut paraître un peu moins stricte
d'un point de vue disciplinaire,
elle règle beaucoup de sujets.
Parce qu'au fond,
qu'est-ce que vous voulez ?
Quel est le sujet qu'il y a derrière ?
C'est 1, la laïcité.
Et 2, un peu l'idée qu'on se fait
de la décence.
On ne veut pas des tenues
trop excentriques.
On a tous connu ça.
On mettait les dernières baskets
et on se faisait refouler
à la porte de l'établissement
parce que chef d'établissement
avait dit pas de baskets.
Donc je trouve que l'approche,
ce que j'ai dit au ministre
quand on en a parlé au début de l'été,
Moi, je suis favorable à l'approche
expérimentation évaluation.
J'étais plutôt favorable
à l'approche par établissement.
Je constate qu'il y a une telle pression
sur les chefs d'établissement,
que expérimenter, évaluer
permettra d'éclairer le débat public.
Donc il y a des expérimentations
et on verra exactement ce que ça donne.
Mais là où je vous rejoins,
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire à l'école ?
Tout ça, il faut le remettre
dans un contexte apaisé.
Parce que ce avec quoi
vous avez commencé est juste.
Très juste.
l'École, ça construit du commun.
C'est pour faire des citoyens,
des républicains.
Et on veut que nos gamins soient bien.
Et donc construire du commun,
c'est pour ça qu'on transmet
la même langue,
les mêmes savoirs, les mêmes...
C'est avoir un espace où il y a
le moins de différences possibles.
Et donc je pense
que l'objectif qu'on vise...
Il faut un certain bon sens,
sortir des débats qui divisent.
Et c'est aussi pour ça
que je ne veux pas que les enfants
de confession musulmane
se sentent exclus ou mal à l'aise à l'école.
Je ne veux pas que celles
qui voudraient mettre telle tenue
se sentent exclus ou mal à l'aise à l'école.
Il faut une forme de bon sens derrière.
Ce qu'on veut faire,
l'objectif de la nation,
c'est au fond qu'il n'y ait rien
qui vous exclut, qui vous sépare.
Et donc 1, on veut éviter les tenues
qui vous renvoie à une religion,
parce que ça vous exclut,
ça vous sépare,
et que ça ne vous met pas
dans un cadre commun.
Et c'est la laïcité.
2, on veut éviter des situations
qui mettent de la stigmatisation sociale,
donc moins on a de débats
sur les marques, mieux c'est.
3, on veut éviter les tenues
trop excentriques qui provoquent.
D'où les expérimentations.
Derrière, il faut sortir
des débats microcosmiques.
C'est construire du commun
dans la même classe.
C'est un sujet plus large,
d'où mon évocation de l'uniforme
à la fin de cette question sur l'abaya.
Autre sujet sur lequel on va avancer,
c'est la question du harcèlement.
Un autre sujet évidemment très,
très important.
On l'a vu encore une fois dans les retours,
que ce soit YouTube ou Instagram,
ces derniers jours.
Ça a été aussi beaucoup dans l'actualité
pour des tristes événements.
En mai dernier, Lindsay,
une adolescente de 13 ans,
s'est suicidée après avoir subi
une vague de harcèlement au collège
et sur les réseaux sociaux.
Elle avait pourtant dénoncé
ce harcèlement dont elle était victime
dès la rentrée de septembre 2022.
Et sa famille avait déposé
deux plaintes au mois de février
et avait aussi averti
la direction de son collège.
Et là, je parle ici du cas de Lindsay,
mais vous l'avez suivi,
je pourrais aussi parler
des cas de Lucas ou encore de Thibault.
Il y a un dispositif, le dispositif pHARe,
qui a été lancé par le gouvernement
contre le harcèlement scolaire.
Ce dispositif,
il était en place au sein du...
Au sein de cette école,
du collège de Lindsay.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui pour être entendu ?
Bon, d'abord, sur le cas de Lindsay,
j'ai vraiment
une pensée affectueuse
pour toute sa famille,
sa maman qui a vu mon épouse
et qui va voir le ministre bientôt.
Et ils ont vécu ce qu'il y a de pire,
de perdre un enfant
qui met fin à ses jours
après une telle situation.
Je ne veux pas rentrer dans le détail,
parce qu'il y a des enquêtes en cours.
Mais ce que vous dites est factuel.
Il y avait eu des démarches,
il y avait eu des réponses de l'école.
Et des premières mesures
qui se sont avérées insuffisantes.
Et le dispositif s'arrêtait là.
C'est un combat absolument essentiel
si on veut que nos enfants
d'abord soient bien à l'école,
puissent bien apprendre.
Et en effet...
Le harcèlement peut être
à la cause de beaucoup de choses ?
Le pire : suicide.
Le décrochage scolaire
dans certains cas.
Ou après le mal-être
et les situations qu'on décrivait
au début de nos discussions.
Donc c'est une cause absolue.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
1, le programme pHARe,
il faut renforcer son effectivité.
Il est là.
On forme les enseignants,
on les sensibilise.
Mais il faut s'assurer
de manière systématique
que la réponse est proportionnée,
suivie et qu'elle écoute.
Le système n'est jamais parfait,
et donc sans relâche, sans relâche.
À cet égard, je pense qu'on est en train
de le renforcer avec des référents.
Je remercie là aussi les enseignants,
les responsables de vie scolaire,
les chefs d'établissement.
Mais aussi on a mis en place des délégués.
Donc les élèves eux-mêmes
sont un peu responsabilisés.
Plus généralement, c'est un peu
une question d'état d'esprit.
Dans les objectifs de l'école,
il y a transmettre les savoirs,
l'esprit critique, et il y a la confiance.
On a besoin d'avoir une école
plus bienveillante.
Et ça c'est un point essentiel
sur tous les sujets de société.
À côté de ça, on a nos dispositifs,
qu'on met en place dès cette rentrée,
qui, je pense, dans quelques-uns
des cas que vous avez évoqués,
mais je ne veux pas faire cas par cas,
peut changer beaucoup de choses,
c'est d'éloigner l'élève qui harcèle.
Quelle était la situation qu'on avait ?
Souvent, il y avait des sanctions.
Elles pouvaient être
une exclusion quelques jours,
des retenus.
Mais c'est la personne victime...
Exactement, c'était l'élève harcelé
qui finissait par changer d'établissement.
Maintenant, c'est inversé.
On prend tout de suite la décision,
et on éloigne,
et on met un dispositif de suivi
sur l'élève qui a harcelé.
Je pense que c'est très important
et c'est un changement complet d'approche.
Et puis à côté de ça...
Donc 1, on renforce le pHARe.
Je pense que tous les enseignants
ont conscience,
mais on renforce la sensibilisation,
on a mis des équipes dédiées.
On met l'éloignement de l'élève qui harcèle.
Et puis à côté,
il faut renforcer le cyberharcèlement
parce que dans tous les cas évoqués,
ce n'est pas qu'un harcèlement à l'école,
c'est que ça continue
sur les boucles WhatsApp, sur Facebook,
sur TikTok, sur Insta, etc.
Plus TikTok.
Facebook est moins utilisé par les jeunes.
Non, non, je sais bien, pardon,
mais je veux être œcuménique.
parce que c'est absolument
tous ces réseaux.
Il y a TikTok, Insta,
et il y a des boucles aussi.
Mais il y a un enjeu de cyberharcèlement.
Donc sur le cyberharcèlement aussi,
on a eu un très gros boulot
qui a été fait avec des associations, etc.
On a le 3018 qui a été mis en place,
et on est en train de passer une loi qui,
cet automne, va être votée,
qui va permettre maintenant,
si je puis dire,
d'éloigner en ligne les cyberharceleurs
en les interdisant de réseaux
pendant six mois,
et s'ils reproduisent pendant douze mois.
Et je pense que c'est aussi
une mesure très importante.
Ça n'a pas été fait jusqu'ici en France.
Donc pour bien comprendre,
c'est de faire en sorte qu'une personne
auteur/autrice de cyberharcèlement...
Qui est signalée...
Puisse être...
Elle n'est plus présente sur les réseaux ?
Une loi va mettre
une procédure en place,
ce qui est permis
grâce aux directives européennes,
en particulier DSA mis en place
et qu'on transcrit dans la loi française.
Donc la loi va mettre en place
une procédure qui va permettre,
contre les auteurs de cyberharcèlement,
de les éloigner, si je puis dire,
des réseaux et de leur possibilité
d'agir sur ces réseaux
pendant les six mois qui suivent.
-Et ça concerne les jeunes,
les adultes, tout le monde ?
Et pour bien comprendre
la forme que ça prend.
C'est une responsabilité des réseaux.
L'idée du coup d'éloigner les personnes
qui font des actes de cyberharcèlement,
quelle que soit la forme,
pour bien comprendre,
qui va décider de cet éloignement ?
Est-ce que c'est la justice ?
Est-ce que c'est le réseau social ?
Alors, je ne veux pas préempter
ce que le législateur va faire.
Mais ce qu'on propose en effet,
c'est que, sur la base
d'une procédure graduée,
c'est que le juge
puisse tout à fait le faire,
mais que quand il y a
des procédures de signalement
et quand les autorités compétentes
le signalent aux réseaux,
ils puissent aussi le décider.
Si je résume,
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent,
c'est une mesure qui n'existe pas,
que vous allez porter,
et on verra si elle est votée,
mais votre objectif,
c'est de faire en sorte que des personnes
auteurs de harcèlement
puissent être éloignées des réseaux
en cas de condamnation par la justice.
Éloignée, ça veut dire,
pendant une période donnée...
Six mois, et douze en cas de récidive.
Ils ne peuvent pas recréer de compte ?
Pour bien comprendre le contexte.
Ça va être tout l'enjeu,
mais on va mettre en place,
c'est ce que prévoit cette directive,
une responsabilité des réseaux sociaux,
c'est-à-dire la personne identifiée,
qui aura fait la procédure
administrativo-judiciaire,
je ne veux pas préempter la solution clé
vers laquelle le législateur ira,
eh bien, sera exclu pendant six mois.
C'est la responsabilité du réseau
de l'exclure pendant six mois.
S'il recrée par d'autres voix
un autre compte
et qu'il reprend
ses activités de harcèlement,
à ce moment-là, la sanction
et la pénalité ira aux réseaux.
C'est la directive européenne
qui nous le permet.
C'est la responsabilité aussi des réseaux
d'appliquer cette loi si elle est votée.
Ils auront des pénalités
s'ils ne le font pas.
C'est une annonce importante.
Mais donc, on renforce,
parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été faites ces dernières années.
C'est un combat absolument majeur
parce qu'il est terrible
pour les enfants, les ados
et les jeunes qui le vivent.
Et donc, on ne lâchera rien.
Et on note que Élisabeth Borne,
la Première Ministre,
a déclaré sur RTL qu'elle annoncerait
un plan d'ici la fin du mois
sur le harcèlement scolaire,
donc on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
dans nos actus du jour
ou dans nos autres formats.
On va passer rapidement
à la question du pacte enseignant.
C'est un sujet important
que vous avez présenté
avec votre ministre de l'Éducation nationale,
Gabriel Attal il y a plusieurs mois,
mais qui a été précisé
au fil des semaines.
Je me permets de l'expliquer
pour que tout le monde ait le contexte.
Après, on va pouvoir rentrer dans le détail
sur le dispositif tel qu'il est.
Le pacte enseignant, il prévoit
le fait que les enseignants
puissent toucher
un complément de salaire
en échange de certaines missions
qu'ils viendraient faire.
Ça implique donc de signer ce pacte,
de rentrer dans ce processus-là.
Les missions dont on parle,
qui sont possibles,
c'est la question de remplacement
de courte durée
de leurs collègues absents,
c'est la question du soutien scolaire,
de l'aide aux devoirs,
de l'aide à l'orientation aussi.
Il y a un système de briques
qui est mis en place.
Et donc, les enseignants,
s'ils le souhaitent,
participent à ce pacte
qui a été annoncé.
Et en parallèle,
pour bien compléter le tout,
on en a là aussi beaucoup
parlé dans l'actu,
il y a une hausse de salaire
qui a été annoncée.
Cette hausse de salaire
pour la rentrée 2023.
elle est de 125 euros,
entre 125 et 259 euros nets par mois
par rapport à la rentrée 2022.
Celle-ci est inconditionnelle.
Elle ne dépend pas de ce que vous allez faire
ou non à dans le cadre du pacte enseignant.
Premier élément peut-être là-dessus,
sur la question plus large
de la rémunération des enseignants.
On sait que c'est un enjeu
pour recruter des enseignants.
Selon un rapport de l'OCDE
qui a effectué une comparaison
entre pays, notamment européens,
en parité de pouvoir d'achat,
ce qui permet une comparaison plus juste,
on va dire, entre les différents pays,
le salaire statutaire
des enseignants en France reste,
et cette augmentation
ne le comble pas,
nettement inférieur
à celui de beaucoup de nos voisins.
On parlait de l'Allemagne comme modèle
sur la question du rythme.
Le salaire en Allemagne, par exemple,
vous le savez très sûrement,
c'est près de 92 000 dollars
en parité de pouvoir d'achat.
Autrement dit, un salaire beaucoup
plus important par rapport à la France,
puisqu'on est en moyenne à 43 000 dollars
avec ce mode de calcul.
Est-ce que cette augmentation
est réellement suffisante
pour faire en sorte d'attirer à nouveau
sur ce métier et valoriser ce métier
qui est évidemment important ?
Alors, les enquêtes de l'OCDE,
elles montrent très clairement
qu'en début de carrière,
on payait beaucoup moins nos enseignants.
On commençait à rattraper
en milieu de carrière.
En fin de carrière, on est
compétitif par rapport aux autres.
Et on a un niveau de retraite qui est
plutôt dans la moyenne haute de l'OCDE,
parce qu'on a un système de retraite
dans la fonction publique qui est meilleur.
Donc, dans le cycle du temps,
ce n'est pas aussi univoque.
Mais là, c'est 15 ans d'ancienneté.
C'est pour ça
que ce qu'on avait besoin de corriger,
c'était le début et le milieu de carrière.
Ce qu'on a fait puisque,
quand j'ai été élu la première fois,
un enseignant titulaire, il était recruté
à 1 600-1 700 euros nets par mois.
Aucun aujourd'hui n'est recruté
en dessous de 2 100 euros nets par mois.
Donc, vous voyez
que l'impact a été massif.
Si je me permets,
juste sur ce point des 2 100 euros,
sur le site du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale,
il y a des personnes qui sont
ce qu'on appelle stagiaires,
donc ils débutent
mais sont à temps plein.
Ceux-ci sont en dessous,
selon les chiffres
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale.
Je prends la peine de vous dire
pour les professeurs titulaires.
Mais une personne stagiaire
n'est pas en début de carrière ?
Une personne stagiaire
est en début de carrière.
Donc là, vous avez le traitement...
Donc c'est bien ce que je dis.
C'est la ligne 2 qu'il faut prendre.
À partir de la ligne 2.
Non, mais c'est la réalité.
C'est pour ça que vous avez des stagiaires,
qui sont encore en formation,
Mais ils sont devant des élèves.
C'est tout à fait vrai,
mais ils sont payés 300 euros de plus
que des gens qui étaient à la ligne 2,
donc professeurs titulaires.
300 euros de plus
qu'au début du quinquennat.
Mais c'est des enseignants.
Stagiaire ici, ça ne...
Ce sont pas enseignants,
mais ils ne sont pas reconnus
comme professeurs titulaires.
Donc ces stagiaires à mi-temps,
je ne veux pas dire de bêtises,
ils devaient être payés 1 500 euros
par mois il y a quatre ans,
donc ils ont eu une augmentation
de 400 euros.
Donc quand on dit
tous les enseignants titulaires,
dans les faits, ce n'est pas le cas.
Il ne faut pas dire tous les enseignants,
les stagiaires et les contractuels
sont en dessous.
Si on dit tous les enseignants titulaires,
ça commence à la ligne 2.
Mais les enseignants en général...
Donc les enseignants...
Les stagiaires,
il y en a qui sont en dessous
comme vous le dites, et les contractuels,
il y en a qui sont en dessous.
C'est important aussi à dire
si on devait être exhaustif,
mais les professeurs titulaires,
dès la première année,
ils sont bien au-dessus de 2 100.
Les contractuels sont entre 1 700
et 2 000 euros bruts selon leur diplôme.
Mais donc, tout le monde
a été revalorisé de manière inédite.
On n'avait pas fait
un tel investissement depuis 90.
Bon, donc, c'est toujours des chiffres.
Je ne sais pas si ça parle aux gens.
C'est important.
Non mais le chiffre macro,
ça fait 3,7 milliards d'euros
l'année dernière et cette année,
à chaque fois,
3,7 plus 3,7 de revalorisation.
Dans un contexte d'inflation,
au passage.
Oui, c'est tout à fait vrai.
Quand vous dites 125 à 250 euros nets,
ça prend l'indice et la partie inflation.
Néanmoins, il y a une augmentation
qui correspond aux engagements
qui ont été pris.
Donc ça,
c'est la partie inconditionnelle.
La grille que vous aviez,
qui était très bien fichue.
On peut la remettre si vous voulez.
C'est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas signé le pacte,
qui fait son service
et il ne fait pas de missions en plus.
Mais qui travaillent déjà...
Qui est devant les élèves
avec ses heures.
Ça dépend après de ses diplômes, etc.
Mais qui fait ses heures.
Après, ça c'est un point clé,
donc on a revalorisé
et on est en train de rattraper
les autres Européens
pour le début et milieu de carrière.
Et c'est une bataille clé
parce qu'il faut re-rendre ce métier
qui est absolument fondamental,
dont on a besoin pour nos enfants,
nos adolescents, attractifs.
Deuxième chose, le pacte,
vous l'avez dit.
Moi, j'y crois beaucoup.
On a besoin d'abord de reconnaître
des tâches qui sont faites
par les enseignants aujourd'hui
pour lesquelles ils ne sont pas payés.
L'aide aux devoirs,
le remplacement des collègues
qui ne sont pas là, etc.
Vous avez énormément de profs,
d'enseignants pardon,
qui font ça, qui ne sont pas mieux payés
que le copain qui fait juste son service.
Le pacte, c'est la reconnaissance
d'un engagement.
Et ensuite on en a besoin
pour faire fonctionner
au plus près du terrain le système.
J'insiste sur un point que vous avez
évoqué, ce sont les remplacements.
On a 15 millions d'heures d'enseignement
qui sont perdues chaque année,
parce que sur des absences très courtes,
il n'y a pas de remplacement.
Alors, une partie,
c'est la faute de notre système.
On met des formations aux enseignants
dans du temps scolaire,
donc on va faire le maximum
pour les enlever.
Mais après,
il y a des écoles qui le font déjà.
Moi j'ai été dans l'Hérault, il y a peu,
dans un collège formidable.
Ils le font en payant
sur des heures sup les profs,
et ils ont en quelque sorte...
Vos heures d'enseignement,
c'est les heures vertes.
Les heures oranges : je n'enseigne pas
mais je suis disponible pour remplacer.
Les heures rouges :
pas du tout disponible.
Je dois corriger des copies ou autre.
Et donc là, on sait chaque jour.
Le matin on arrive.
Le prof d'anglais n'est pas là.
La classe va être prise par le prof de math.
Mais très précisément,
et au-delà du fait
que le cours d'anglais peut être
remplacé par le cours de maths,
ce qui amène, selon les syndicats,
à certains problèmes.
Certains disent qu'on ne rattrape pas
forcément un retard qu'on aurait pris.
C'est du bon sens élémentaire.
Le jour où le prof de maths...
Si j'ai que mon prof d'anglais
qui est absent toute l'année,
que c'est remplacé par des maths.
Ça, on le règle différemment.
C'est une confusion qui est malhonnête.
C'est une question
qui revient beaucoup.
Je me permets de la régler.
Les remplacements longs,
on ne les gère pas comme ça.
Quand je dis tout le temps,
je n'entends pas toute l'année.
D'abord, il faut mesurer une chose.
Durant mon premier quinquennat,
je me suis battu pour qu'on améliore
les remplacements
partout dans l'école.
Les seules absences qu'on mesurait,
c'est celles de plus de 15 jours.
En cas d'absence de plus de 15 jours,
le rectorat envoie quelqu'un
et vous avez dans tous les rectorats
des professeurs qui sont
parfois des stagiaires
ou des professeurs en appoint
et qui sont des collègues
qui sont déployés,
et qui sont aussi pour certains
des enseignants très expérimentés,
qui sont déployés dans les écoles
ou les collèges et les lycées.
Plus les collèges et les lycées,
et qui viennent faire des remplacements.
Donc, si vous avez pendant quatre mois
votre prof de maths qui est absent,
là, le rectorat doit dépêcher
un remplaçant,
et il y aura
un enseignant en mathématiques
qui viendra remplacer.
Là, on parle pas des absences
qui peuvent parfois être répétées,
mais qui sont des absences très courtes.
Et donc là, si le collègue d'anglais
prend l'heure,
quand le prof de math revient,
il reprend une heure d'anglais.
Très rapidement sur la question
du pacte enseignant.
Très rapidement donc, on le redit,
en plus du travail de base,
plus d'heures pour certaines missions
mais qui sont rémunérées,
ce qui vient compléter le salaire.
L'enjeu ici, c'est la question
de la charge de travail
des enseignants et des professeurs.
Selon la direction de l'évaluation,
de la prospective et de la performance,
qui date de 2022,
les enseignants français au primaire
et au collège-lycée
sont parmi ceux qui travaillent le plus
en Europe déjà aujourd'hui,
sans parler donc
des missions supplémentaires.
On a mis un graphique.
Compte étant tenu des missions.
Non, c'est des chiffres de 2020-2021.
Non mais ce que je veux dire,
si c'est l'enquête de la DEPP...
Oui, c'est ça, exactement.
L'enquête de cette direction
que vous avez citée,
intègre ce que font...
Mais c'est en fait...
Les heures dues par le système
et les heures que font
beaucoup de collègues.
Mais c'est inégalement réparti
et elles ne sont pas aujourd'hui valorisées.
Très rapidement, sur le pacte enseignant,
dans les différentes briques.
Je mettrai des liens en description
pour tout le monde comprenne bien.
On a des briques
sur l'aide à l'orientation,
sur l'aide aux devoirs, sur des dispositifs
mis en place à partir de la rentrée,
pour essayer de combler les inégalités.
L'enjeu qui est soulevé par un certain nombre
d'enseignants; c'est que,
non seulement d'un point de vue
de la rémunération,
les enseignants doivent travailler
encore plus pour gagner plus.
Et d'un point de vue
de la charge de travail totale
sur ces nouvelles missions,
elle soit en fait impossible
à aller chercher,
puisqu'ils sont déjà parmi les enseignants
qui travaillent le plus.
Alors, deux choses.
La première, c'est la meilleure défense
de la nécessité de revoir
le temps scolaire dans l'année.
Qu'on évoquait avant.
Quand vous voyez ça, vous voyez bien
qu'on ne peut pas être en même temps
ceux qui avons le moins de semaines
de temps scolaire dans l'année,
ce qui est le cas,
on est parmi les plus bas.
Ça, c'est une étude de l'OCDE.
La deuxième chose,
c'est que cette heure moyenne annuelle
qui est prise en compte,
intègre beaucoup des missions,
enfin les missions qui sont dans le pacte.
Mon point, c'est de dire que devoirs faits,
c'est un système qui existe aujourd'hui.
Le remplacement, il existe en théorie,
il est dans le code.
Simplement, aujourd'hui, le système repose
sur une partie des enseignants
et ceux qui donnent plus
que ce qu'ils doivent de manière légale
ne sont pas reconnus comme il faut.
Et donc c'est pour ça
que j'insiste sur ce point,
le pacte ne vient pas
inventer des nouvelles missions.
Ces missions existent.
Pour certaines...
Ceux qui signent le pacte
ne travailleront pas plus.
Mais en fait, mon point,
c'est de dire,
les enseignants qui signent le pacte
je ne veux pas préempter,
mais ce sont déjà des gens qui travaillent
plus que ce qu'on croit qu'ils travaillent.
Mais ces heures-là ne sont pas reconnues,
et c'est ce que le système doit.
Dans votre 720 heurs faits par la DEPP,
il y a les heures de remplacement.
Mais elles ne sont pas toujours effectives,
et donc nous on les rend effectives.
Donc dans ces 720 heures...
On va passer à un autre sujet,
mais pour résumer,
ces heures-là sont intégrées
dans le pacte enseignant.
Mais bien sûr, parce qu'aujourd'hui,
le remplacement doit être légalement fait.
Comment vous expliquez qu'on ait un système
qui ait 15 millions d'heures non remplacées ?
2, le système de forfait existe.
Les systèmes d'accompagnement existent,
mais ils reposent sur des enseignants
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas reconnus
par le système et bien valorisés.
Le pacte, il va permettre, vous l'avez dit,
l'augmentation pour un prof,
un enseignant qui ne prend pas le pack,
c'est 125 à 250 euros nets de plus par mois
de rentrée à rentrée.
Ce chiffre, il va être porté à 500 euros,
voire 700 euros dans le lycée professionnel
de plus par mois.
C'est très clair.
Et on verra l'application
dans les prochaines semaines.
Je peux vous dire que ça change la vie.
Si vous voulez bien,
on va passer à un autre sujet.
Ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on parle
et je me doute qu'il y a beaucoup d'étudiants
qui attendent qu'on parle,
et de non-étudiants...
Est-ce que j'ai le droit de dire
à la cavalcade
tout ce qu'on va faire à l'école en rentrée,
hyper vite ?
Tant qu'on a le temps d'évoquer la suite,
ça ne me gêne pas.
Mais en cette rentrée,
on va commencer à accueillir
dans les quartiers en difficulté
dès deux ans à la maternelle.
On continue de dédoubler
les grandes sections de maternelle.
Un truc dont je suis le plus fier,
c'est le dédoublement,
dans les zones REP et REP+,
du CP-CE1.
On va, entre cette rentrée et la suivante,
généraliser pour la grande section
de maternelle, hyper important.
On met en place
plus d'enseignements fondamentaux
au primaire, la demi-heure de sport
partout au primaire
et l'évaluation CP-CE1-CM1,
mais aussi au collège, 6ème-4ème.
C'est sur la base de ces évaluations
qu'on va pouvoir mieux identifier
les élèves pré-décrocheurs ou décrocheurs
et les difficultés et les accompagner.
On va permettre,
pour tous ceux qui ont des difficultés,
d'avoir des pré-rentrées
et de mieux les accompagner.
Plus des heures de soutien.
On met en place l'éducation artistique
et culturelle au primaire.
À la 6ème, on va permettre
de mettre en place une heure de soutien
en maths ou en français
pour ceux qui en ont besoin.
- On en a parlé.
- C'est hyper important.
On développera les éco-délégués,
ce qui est un formidable succès
ces dernières années,
pour que l'écologie
soit pleinement intégrée dans la formation
et que nos collégiens et lycéens soient
des acteurs de l'écologie.
Et je veux,
en particulier sur notre objectif forêt,
c'est un point hyper important,
je veux qu'on ait,
dès la 6ème de cette année,
qu'on commence à avoir des élèves
qui plantent des arbres,
et qu'on ait cette génération
où chaque collégien aura planté son arbre.
On n'arrivera pas à le faire
pour l'intégralité des 6ème,
mais si on a chaque génération
qui plante son arbre,
ils vont nous aider à aller
à notre milliard de reboisement.
C'est hyper important
pour la Sainte-Catherine.
Ensuite, je continue...
Ce n'est pas ça qui inversera la courbe
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Pas plus que ce que vous m'avez dit
sur prendre moins l'avion.
Les avions un peu plus qu'un arbre.
Non, c'est tous ces gestes,
ce que je vous ai dit sur l'avion.
Plus j'évite un vol inutile,
plus en effet je reboise.
Comme vous l'avez dit, il y a des choses
qui ont plus d'impact que d'autres.
C'est pas juste de dire que ce qui est
dans le débat public a plus d'impact.
Non, ce n'est pas ce que je dis.
Moi aussi, j'ai ma part du colibri.
J'ai le droit, et elle a autant de gueule
que celle des copains.
Celle-là, c'est les scientifiques
en l'occurrence.
Mais moi aussi, c'est les scientifiques :
il faut reboiser.
Oui, ça, on est d'accord.
Ensuite le collège, on continue,
on va mettre en place dès la 5ème,
la journée avenir,
une demi-journée tous les 15 jours
où on présente les métiers aux jeunes.
Ensuite, on mettra en place,
on reprend une heure de maths...
On en a parlé dans les actus du jour.
Dans le lycée.
Et on fait la réforme du bac
qui fait que les spécialités
ne seront pas en mars mais en juin.
Je pense que les lycéens
sont au courant.
On fait la révision et Parcoursup.
On n'aura pas le temps d'en parler.
Et on fait une vraie révolution
sur le lycée pro qui est une cause nationale.
Un tiers des lycéens.
Et on fait un changement profond
grâce aux profs,
grâce aux chefs d'établissement
et grâce aux élèves,
On passe à la question des étudiants.
Il y a énormément de sujets,
c'est normal, c'est une interview de rentrée.
Merci à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent,
si vous suivez cette interview en direct.
On passe à la question des étudiants.
On va aller plus largement
sur la question de la jeunesse,
mais sur la question des étudiants :
pour permettre à chacun
d'avoir des études
dans des bonnes conditions
et d'accueillir tous les étudiants
qui le souhaitent,
il y a évidemment une question de moyens,
une question de budget.
Quand on se rend sur le site
du ministère de L'enseignement supérieur,
on apprend,
c'est le ministère qui l'indique,
que le budget par étudiant
est en baisse ces dernières années.
Alors, ça ne remonte pas
qu'à votre quinquennat, c'est depuis 2014.
On est en moyenne sur une baisse
de 1,4 % du budget par étudiant.
Même la ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur, Sylvie Retailleau,
a expliqué aux présidents d'université
qu'il n'y aurait pas de miracle,
en cette rentrée.
Les présidents d'université étaient inquiets
de voir d'un côté, certes,
une ambition sur l'enseignement
supérieur, mais de l'autre côté,
un besoin, un enjeu, une demande
de réduction des coûts à l'université,
dans le contexte actuel.
La crainte qui est très présente,
ma question est un peu longue,
mais j'arrive au bout.
Est-ce que le risque, là,
ce n'est pas une sélection à l'université
qui ne dit pas son nom
mais qui finit par s'appliquer
avec des universités qui n'ont plus
les moyens d'accueillir des nouveaux élèves ?
Non, je ne crois pas du tout,
mais je vais vous expliquer.
D'abord, je veux redire
dans quel pays nous vivons.
L'université est gratuite en France.
Regardez à travers le monde,
là aussi, qui est comparable.
Durant mon premier quinquennat,
nous avons pris en charge
la Sécurité sociale étudiante.
C'est plusieurs centaines
d'euros par an pour un étudiant.
Parfois, ça dépassait le millier.
Et donc nous sommes dans un pays,
et un tiers de nos étudiants sont boursiers.
Alors après, il y a une échelle
selon les revenus des parents,
mais un tiers sont boursiers.
Donc nous avons l'un des systèmes
qui socialisent le plus
le coût des études supérieures.
Ça, c'est une réalité.
Et quand on parle
de nos études supérieures,
il ne faut jamais perdre ça de vue
parce que c'est une force de la France.
mais on a un modèle
extraordinairement généreux.
Mais un jeune sur quatre
vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
malgré cette situation.
C'est tout à fait vrai.
Mais ça montre... Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on doit avoir aussi
un système plus clair.
On a plus de 80 % d'une génération
qui arrive au bac.
Quel est le but
des études supérieures ?
De pouvoir avoir un métier,
un avenir qu'on choisit.
Or, aujourd'hui,
quand je regarde les chiffres,
50 % des jeunes
qui s'inscrivent en licence
ne vont pas se présenter à l'examen,
ou l'avoir.
Donc on a un énorme problème
d'orientation
et on a une forme de gâchis collectif.
Ou de moyens mis à l'université.
Non, ce n'est pas des moyens.
Avec les moyens qu'on met,
on doit faire beaucoup mieux.
D'abord, on doit avoir
de la transparence pour les élèves
et les familles sur ce qu'il y a
au bout d'une formation,
et pour nous, pour la collectivité,
et pour les universités.
Les universités sont autonomes.
Mais quand vous avez des formations
qui, depuis des années,
ne diplôment quasiment pas...
Vous pensez auxquelles ?
Non, je ne stigmatise personne,
je veux pour la transparence.
Je veux qu'on mette en place,
on a commencé, la transparence,
exactement comme on fait
pour le lycée pro.
Vous avez deux critères.
Est-ce que les élèves ont un diplôme ?
Enfin les étudiants.
Et est-ce qu'après le diplôme,
ils ont des emplois ?
Quand vous avez des formations
où vous avez une minorité de jeunes
qui vont à l'examen,
qui ont un diplôme et quasiment aucun
qui ont un emploi, pardon.
Il y a un enjeu d'orientation.
Mais il y a un enjeu.
Attendez, c'est hyper important.
C'est la révolution que j'ai demandée
pour la rentrée prochaine
et les universités
doivent faire beaucoup mieux.
Elles doivent avoir le courage de dire
on ne laisse pas ouvertes des formations
parce qu'on a des profs sur ces formations.
C'est un peu ce qu'on fait parfois.
Et on doit dire en face
est-ce que cette formation,
d'abord, elle me permet
de former des jeunes
et elle me permet d'avoir un emploi ?
À l'inverse, j'ai des formations aujourd'hui,
qui se passent dans de mauvaises conditions
parce que beaucoup trop de jeunes
s'inscrivent.
Or, elles permettent
d'avoir des diplômes et des emplois.
Dans la question
des moyens à l'université.
Donc, les moyens,
honnêtement, on va...
On n'est pas un pays qui sous-investit
sur son enseignement supérieur.
On est parmi les plus.
Mais il y a un coût par étudiant
en baisse.
Sur la précarité...
Non, attendez,
c'est hyper important ce qu'on se dit.
Le système ne pourra pas
être plus efficace
s'il n'y a pas d'abord un système
qui fait davantage contribuer
ceux qui ont plus de moyens.
On est le seul.
Plusieurs universités sont rentrées
là-dedans,
y compris vis à vis
des étudiants étrangers.
Aujourd'hui, vous êtes fils
de milliardaires américains, africains,
ou asiatiques,
vous arrivez
dans une université française,
tout vous est payé.
Il n'y a pas un pays au monde
qui fait ça.
Donc on doit aussi réfléchir
à comment on met à contribution
les gens qui ont le plus de moyens,
si on veut bien faire.
Ensuite, on doit avoir le courage
de revoir nos formations
et de se demander si elles sont
diplômantes, qualifiantes.
Et il faut ensuite que les universités
développent des formations plus courtes
et plus qualifiantes.
Et de le faire au plus près du terrain.
Transition avec votre question
sur la précarité étudiante,
parce que qu'elle est
une des sources de la précarité ?
C'est le coût de la vie.
Justement, une question...
Et donc, on doit,
en lien avec les universités,
les écoles d'ingénieurs,
les écoles de commerce,
développer beaucoup plus
de formations courtes,
c'est à dire entre un et trois ans,
diplômantes et qualifiantes,
dans des villes périphériques,
dans des villes moyennes.
Mais sur le coût de la vie, il y a des choses
qui sont indépendantes quasiment
du lieu où vous vivez.
Un exemple important, c'est la question
de la hausse des prix, de l'inflation.
Alors c'est plus cher à Paris
d'aller au supermarché
que dans une ville moins peuplée.
Mais tout de même, globalement,
les prix augmentent partout, on le sait.
C'est pour ça
qu'on a revalorisé les bourses.
Justement, c'est une question
très rapidement,
avant de passer à autre chose,
c'est la question de la bourse.
C'est évidemment un dispositif majeur
pour aider les étudiants.
Elle a augmenté de 37 euros
en cette année pour tous les échelons,
donc pour les personnes les plus...
Après les concertations qu'a faites
la ministre.
Qui a été pris par le gouvernement.
Et donc sur ce sujet précisément,
pour les plus modestes,
le dernier échelon, ça correspond
à une augmentation à hauteur de l'inflation,
donc aux alentours de 5,8 %.
Merci beaucoup.
L'enjeu, soulevé notamment
par les syndicats étudiants,
c'est que certes l'inflation est à 5 %,
mais l'augmentation des prix
des éléments achetés par des étudiants,
notamment l'alimentation,
n'a pas augmenté de 5 %
mais a augmenté de 15 %.
Autrement dit, le retour
d'un certain nombre d'étudiants,
c'est que certes il y a une augmentation,
mais qui ne fait pas face
à l'augmentation des prix
pour un étudiant.
Alors d'abord, c'est un sujet
qui est très important.
Je le redis, on est dans un pays
où on accompagne beaucoup,
et je m'en félicite, c'est une force.
Nos étudiants, on va de toute façon
évaluer et continuer de suivre.
Et donc on va regarder
dans les prochaines semaines.
On essaie plutôt de se battre
pour baisser les prix alimentaires.
Donc on pourrait augmenter les bourses.
On ne laissera pas des jeunes...
Je ne suis pas pour qu'on l'augmente
pour toutes les catégories,
ce qu'on a fait une première fois,
mais pour les catégories les plus modestes,
où les jeunes sont les plus en difficulté.
Qu'on ait un geste supplémentaire,
s'il y a une confirmation
dans les prochaines semaines
sur la question,
la rentrée n'est pas encore faite,
s'il y a une confirmation
sur les prix de l'alimentation,
je pense qu'il faudra le regarder.
Après la bataille qu'on mène,
c'est plutôt de faire baisser les prix.
Qu'est-ce qu'on regarde ?
Nos agriculteurs,
ils ne font pas des surprofits.
Il faut les protéger parce qu'ils vivent déjà
de grandes difficultés.
Mais on a quelques groupes
de l'agroalimentaire qui font des surprofits,
qui ont passé
des hausses de prix massives.
Et c'est plutôt d'ailleurs les industriels
qui sont sur les biens
qu'achètent beaucoup, les étudiants,
les gens les plus modestes, etc.
Donc là, on est
dans un rapport de force
où on est en train de les contraindre
et de les menacer,
pour que les prix baissent.
Donc, je préférerais,
de manière générale,
qu'on arrive à faire baisser les prix
et qu'on n'ait pas besoin d'augmenter
les bourses pour les étudiants,
en tout cas les plus modestes,
sinon, on le fera.
Donc, si la hausse des prix se poursuit,
il y aura une augmentation des bourses
pour les échelons les plus importants.
Dans les autres éléments
qui concernent la précarité des jeunes,
c'est un sujet très vaste,
Ça peut être frustrant
de ne pas pouvoir aborder
toutes les problématiques
de notre génération.
Mais il y a notamment
la question des soins de santé.
En 2023, près de 4 millions de Françaises
sont victimes de précarité menstruelle.
Donc, lorsqu'une femme ne peut pas
se fournir en protections hygiéniques
par manque tout simplement de moyens.
Ce chiffre-là, il est important,
c'est quasiment deux fois plus qu'en 2021.
Donc on voit que c'est un problème
qui prend de l'ampleur.
En mars, il me semble
que votre gouvernement avait annoncé
le remboursement des protections périodiques
réutilisables pour les moins de 25 ans.
Ma question est très simple.
Est-ce que c'est toujours d'actualité ?
Et si oui, quelle forme ça va prendre
pour ces étudiantes ?
J'ai juste un micro point,
je recherchais les chiffres,
il ne faut pas oublier les APL aussi,
qui ont été revalorisées à 3,5 %.
Il y avait une baisse
en début de quinquennat.
5 euros qui avaient été pris,
on a fait plus que les rattraper.
Et là, la revalorisation. Donc...
Je veux bien le prendre comme un sparadrap,
mais quand même.
La baisse vaut nettement moins
que la suppression
de la sécurité sociale étudiante.
Mais là, je le rappelais,
ça vient en plus du reste.
Oui, l'engagement sera tenu
sur les protections hygiéniques réutilisables
pour les moins de 25, 25 ans compris.
Elles seront remboursées
en 2024 en pharmacie,
et en 2025
sur une plateforme en ligne dédiée.
Qui permettra
d'acheter ces protections ?
Exactement.
Et l'engagement qui a été pris,
vous parlez de santé et de prévention.
C'est un engagement très important
sur le plan social.
Puisque vous parlez de prévention,
je rappelle aussi l'engagement
que j'ai pris sur les préservatifs.
Avec la gratuité des préservatifs.
Jusqu'à 25 ans,
qui est hyper important
et sur lequel
il faut continuer d'expliquer.
C'est un élément de prévention
hyper important,
donc n'oubliez pas que c'est gratuit.
Autre sujet
que je vous propose d'aborder.
On approche de la fin,
mais rapidement.
On a parlé de sujets généraux
en début d'entretien,
de la question de l'environnement,
de la question de la santé mentale,
de la question de l'éducation.
Plein d'autres sujets
qu'on pourrait évoquer.
Mais on a essayé de se pencher
sur certains de ces éléments-là.
On a parlé des étudiants.
Il faut évidemment avoir en tête
que tout le monde n'est pas étudiant,
ou évidemment à l'école.
Et c'est justement un chiffre
qui est assez important.
On estime,
selon les chiffres d'Eurostat,
que c'est un jeune sur huit
qui est ni étudiant,
ni en formation, ni en emploi.
Un jeune sur huit, c'est 12,8 %
des jeunes de 15 à 29 ans,
et c'est un nombre qui ne baisse pas
ces dernières années.
Ah si, on est en train de le baisser.
Alors, selon les derniers chiffres de 2021,
c'est stable a minima jusque 2021
et on verra sur les chiffres suivants.
On est en train de baisser le chiffre
de ce qu'on appelle les NEET,
qui sont ni en emploi ni en formation,
même avant 21.
Je ne sais pas
quelles étaient vos sources.
Là, c'est Eurostat.
Avec l'apprentissage, je...
On mettra, dans tous les cas,
les éléments.
On passera les chiffres là-dessus.
Ce qui est un des points clés.
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire ?
1, d'abord, la conséquence de...
En effet ce sacrifice,
en quelque sorte, de la société.
On avait trop de jeunes qui n'étaient
ni en emploi ni en formation.
C'est le décrochage.
Donc là, c'est la bataille qu'on mène
sur les savoirs fondamentaux,
pour l'évaluation, pour lutter
contre le décrochage avant et au collège.
Et c'est tout le boulot qu'on fait
sur le lycée pro,
d'où venaient beaucoup de ces NEET,
où on met en place
un plan zéro décrocheurs.
Qui ont arrêté leurs études au lycée.
Et souvent ils les arrêtent
parce qu'il y a un dégoût de l'école,
parce qu'on n'a pas bien acquis
les savoirs fondamentaux
et qu'on est envoyé en 6ème alors qu'on
ne sait pas bien lire, écrire et compter.
Donc on est noyé, et puis on conçoit
un dégoût complet de l'école.
Donc ça, c'est tout
ce que j'ai dit avant sur l'école
qui va permettre de le réduire,
et la réforme du lycée pro.
2, c'est ensuite c'aller vers ce que j'ai
commencé à dire sur l'université.
Pourquoi on a beaucoup de jeunes
sans formation ou sans emploi ?
Parce qu'on a beaucoup de jeunes
qui vont dès après bac
vers un système universitaire
qui n'est pas adapté pour eux.
Quand je vous dis,
et ce sont nos chiffres officiels,
qu'on a 50 % des jeunes
qui vont se présenter à l'examen en L1,
où sont les 50 % autres ?
Alors certains se réorientent.
Certains vont finir par y aller
l'année d'après, etc.
Mais vous en perdez plein
qui ont des problèmes d'orientation.
- Donc on doit améliorer l'orientation...
- Dès la 5ème.
Mais même avec Parcoursup,
c'est le même boulot.
Et avoir un système
beaucoup plus transparent,
qui accompagne mieux humainement,
c'est la réforme de Parcoursup,
et qui est plus transparent pour arrêter
avec les formations qui ne mènent nulle part.
3, c'est l'apprentissage.
Et ça, c'est la révolution
qu'on a mise en place.
Pour ça qu'on a commencé
à faire baisser les chiffres.
Il y a cinq ans, on avait entre 230
et 250 000 apprentis par an.
Au moment où je vous parle,
on est autour de 900 000 apprentis,
et on touchera le million d'apprentis par an
et de manière durable.
Ça, c'est une révolution,
parce qu'on a des diplômés
dans ces 900 000 aujourd'hui.
Il y en a qui étaient
dans le système éducatif avant,
mais il y en a d'autres
qui étaient laissés pour compte.
Et ils s'insèrent beaucoup mieux.
C'est ce qui permet d'améliorer
progressivement le taux d'activité
et le taux d'emploi
des moins de 25 ans.
Et puis après, on a mis en place
des dispositifs d'aide, comme la garantie.
C'est tout le mécanisme
qu'on a mis en place pendant le Covid,
un jeune une solution.
Le contrat d'engagement jeune.
Mais la plateforme un jeune une solution,
c'est celle qui vous permet,
quand vous êtes dans cette situation,
de soumettre votre cas
et vous avez une réponse dédiée,
qui peut être une formation courte,
un contrat d'engagement jeune,
un emploi, etc.
Mais là-dessus, plus largement,
c'est une question aussi
qui revient beaucoup.
Alors il y a des débats
depuis longtemps sur ce sujet-là.
Les chercheurs aussi
qui se penchent sur le sujet.
C'est la question de la situation
des jeunes en France
en termes d'accès, y compris sur les aides
qui peuvent être proposées.
Vous serez d'accord avec moi,
à 18 ans, on peut voter,
on peut s'engager en politique.
on commence souvent à travailler
pour financer ses études à côté.
Bref, on est présent dans la vie active,
on est responsable pénalement.
Une demande qui est présente
depuis longtemps,
c'est une demande
de la part des syndicats,
c'est la question des aides proposées,
notamment pour des jeunes
qui seraient sortis du circuit,
qui seraient en difficulté,
et qui ne se retrouvent pas
systématiquement avec les mêmes aides
que les adultes qui auraient
plus de 25 ans par exemple.
Et donc une des questions
qui fait beaucoup débat,
c'est la question du RSA,
la question d'élargir
avec le même fonctionnement
et le même principe le RSA
pour les plus de 25 ans
que pour les moins de 25 ans.
Ce sujet revient souvent sur la table
à chaque élection présidentielle.
Aujourd'hui, quelle est votre position
et qu'est-ce qui fait
que vous ne souhaitez pas
qu'un jeune qui présente des difficultés
pour toutes les raisons qu'on a pu voir,
quelles qu'elles soient,
ne puisse pas bénéficier de cette aide-là
ou pas de la même façon ?
D'abord, on est en train de faire
une réforme du RSA
dans le cadre de France Travail.
Le nouveau nom de Pôle Emploi.
Et nous venons le Pôle emploi,
qu'on rapproche avec les missions locales
et tous les acteurs pour que ça se simplifie.
C'est qu'on doit mieux accompagner
celles et ceux qui sont loin de l'emploi,
qui sont un RSA,
mieux les former,
répondre aussi
aux difficultés qu'ils ont,
pas que de qualifications,
mais des problèmes de logement,
de transport, de garde d'enfants,
et aussi parfois recréer les incitations
qui font que l'emploi est plus intéressant
que d'être aidé.
Aujourd'hui, pourquoi on a un système
qui commence,
et depuis toujours dans notre droit,
à 25 ans ?
Parce que jusqu'à 25 ans,
on prévoit une solidarité familiale.
Et donc ce qui est vrai,
c'est qu'on est dans un système où,
et ça correspond aussi à la manière
dont les bourses sont pensées, etc,
on regarde la capacité contributive
de la famille.
Donc il y a une dépendance
Oui, mais on responsabilise les familles.
Et objectivement,
dans un pays comme le nôtre,
où on a déjà socialisé
beaucoup de choses,
c'est la communauté nationale
qui paye pour beaucoup.
Elle paye votre école, votre collège,
votre lycée, votre université.
Elle paye une bonne partie
de votre santé,
une bonne partie
des sujets du grand âge,
et on est en train
de continuer à réformer.
Est-ce que la priorité,
c'est de continuer à étendre le domaine
qui est à la fin payé par quelqu'un
qui est le contribuable ?
Moi je pense que notre système,
il n'est plus adapté.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On a un système
qui dépend de votre cas.
Et donc quand vous êtes un jeune,
dans le cas que vous évoquez,
si vous pouvez aller vers l'apprentissage,
on vous envoie vers l'apprentissage,
et vous êtes payé par l'employeur
avec une aide de l'État.
Et si vous êtes sorti du circuit ?
D'abord, il n'y a aucune fatalité.
À 18 ans, pardon, mais il faut
que le système vous responsabilise.
Et donc il n'y a aucune fatalité
pour dire 1, on vous amène, je l'espère,
vers l'emploi plein et entier
ou vers les études pleines et entières.
Ça, le système le prévoit,
et vous accompagne et les paye.
3, c'est l'apprentissage
qui est une formidable voie de passage
pour aller vers la professionnalisation,
où on a simplifié, où on aide.
Vous êtes payé par l'employeur
avec une aide importante de l'État.
4, si vous décrochez beaucoup plus,
ce qui est le cas que vous avez en tête,
on a mis en place des systèmes ad hoc,
et le contrat d'engagement jeune,
je le crois préférable au RSA,
parce qu'il permet de vous accompagner,
de vous former.
Ça peut se compléter.
Non, mais il est plus exigeant
en termes d'heures et d'accompagnement.
Et honnêtement,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur le RSA ?
On est en train de renforcer les exigences
et les mécanismes de responsabilité,
parce que le système
tel qu'il avait été pensé en 1988,
il avait complètement perdu la voie
qui était la partie insertion.
Au fond, c'est un contrat.
On vous donne un revenu de solidarité,
mais vous devez vous former,
rester dans la société,
tout faire pour revenir
à un moment vers l'emploi.
On avait laissé tomber
par manque d'investissement.
On ne mettait pas assez
de travailleurs sociaux.
Et puis par désengagement.
Honnêtement, c'est quand même
souvent des situations dramatiques.
Pour les plus de 25 ans,
on essaye de faire cette révolution,
c'est à dire de changer complètement
le RSA avec France Travail
pour aller responsabiliser, réinvestir,
remettre de l'aide hors qualification.
Mais est-ce que c'est une question
de responsabilités ou de détresse ?
Pour beaucoup de jeunes,
on parlait de santé mentale,
les questions économiques sont liées.
On est en train de ramener le RSA
à quelque chose qui ressemble
au contrat d'engagement jeune,
en termes d'exigence.
On a bâti.
Donc c'est le modèle des jeunes
qui est appliqué, plutôt que l'inverse.
Je trouve qu'il est mieux,
parce qu'il est beaucoup plus,
entre guillemets,
contraignant et responsabilisant.
La garantie qui existait
était un mécanisme assez lourd.
La garantie, c'était de l'argent
qu'on versait aux 18-25 ans,
en situation de très grand décrochage,
mais avec un engagement assez fort.
Et vous estimez que quand on est au RSA,
on n'a pas la volonté
spontanément, naturellement,
de vouloir un travail ou s'en sortir ?
Non, je dis il y a une palette.
Il ne faut jamais faire de raccourcis.
Dans nos compatriotes qui sont au RSA,
on a des gens qui sont.
chômeurs de longue durée
qui sont tombés au RSA,
et qui, si on leur donne un coup de pouce,
la formation qui va bien
retrouvent un emploi.
On baisse le RSA
dans plein de départements.
2, vous avez des gens sortis
depuis longtemps, il faut les requalifier
et ils ont besoin parfois
d'une formation de 6-12- 24 mois.
Il faut la payer
et c'est ce qu'on fait avec France Travail.
3, on a certains de nos compatriotes
qui ont besoin de formation,
mais qui se sont désocialisés,
et qui ont du mal à se lever,
ont du mal à se remettre
dans des conditions de vie.
Il faut les accompagner.
Et ce n'est pas que des formations.
Ils ont besoin qu'on leur tende la main.
Et ça, ce sont des travailleurs sociaux.
C'est l'investissement qu'on fait.
Il y a des associations
qui font un formidable travail.
Luttent contre la pauvreté.
Mais les missions locales,
donc c'est ce qu'on intègre dedans.
Et puis 4, on a des gens qui sont bloqués,
qui sont sans solution.
Je vais vous prendre un exemple
très concret :
une maman solo qui est au RSA,
si vous lui proposez un emploi
mais qu'elle n'a pas de solution de garde,
elle ne peut pas prendre l'emploi.
Et donc, c'est tout le non monétaire
et le non formation,
mais qui sont trouver
des solutions de garde d'enfants,
de déplacement, de logement.
- Je me permets de revenir.
- Et dernier cas.
Vous avez des gens au RSA
qui ne veulent pas bosser, ça existe aussi.
Vous considérez
qu'ils sont si nombreux que ça ?
Je suis incapable, et je crois que personne
n'est capable de les chiffrer.
Mais vous avez toute cette réalité,
et on a tendance à caricaturer.
Les uns disent il y en a zéro,
les autres disent ils sont tous comme ça.
Moi je vous dis,
c'est la réalité à peu près.
Je crois avoir couvert toutes
les situations des personnes au RSA.
La question est de savoir
la répartition de chacun.
Non, la question, et c'est
ce qu'on veut faire avec France Travail,
c'est ce que je veux faire pour les 18-25 ans
qui sont dans cette situation-là,
c'est responsabiliser, aider.
Et donc, dans tous les cas que j'ai évoqués,
c'est des gens qui ont besoin
d'une aide adaptée,
qui va être parfois un peu plus de formation,
parfois d'être aidé sur les enfants.
Donc il faut que l'aide
soit quasiment cousue-main,
parce que le système est trop large,
il faut du sur mesure.
Et à côté de ça, d'autres ont besoin
d'être plus responsabilisés.
Très rapidement,
il y a énormément de messages.
Aucune démago, mais il faut essayer
de se dire les choses.
Il y a beaucoup de messages
sur YouTube et sur TikTok, on est en direct,
sur la question de Parcoursup.
Vaste sujet, on a parlé de la question
de la pédagogie et de la transparence
sur ces éléments-là.
Mais un élément peut-être
plus brûlant, on va dire, dans l'actualité,
c'est la question des candidats
qui sont en attente d'affectation.
Alors, début juillet,
on n'a pas les chiffres plus récents,
si vous les avez très bien,
ils étaient encore 77 000
en attente d'affectation.
- Ça a baissé.
- J'imagine bien.
Pour autant, il y en a, et on a des tweets
qui permettent de le montrer,
de certains qui réagissent.
"J-4, toujours aucune admission
sur Parcoursup."
Ça date il y a trois ou quatre jours.
"18 vœux refusés, 4 vœux en attente
à quatre jours de la rentrée."
Je vais vous donner des chiffres.
À 10 jours de la fin
de la phase d'admission,
donc d'abord
on s'améliore chaque année,
il reste 2 309 candidats sans proposition.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour eux ?
500 de moins que l'année dernière.
Ils sont pris en charge par des commissions
d'accompagnement de rectorat.
Donc en fait, on les fait à la main.
Donc dedans, parce que vous savez
que Parcoursup,
on a ceux qui sortent de Terminale
et ceux qui se réorientent,
dedans, on a 1 769 bachelières
et bacheliers,
et 303 étudiants en réorientation.
- Sans affectation.
- Exactement.
Donc là, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
C'est les commissions dans chaque rectorat,
qui vont les appeler
pour leur trouver une solution.
Donc c'est au cas par cas
pour les milliers d'étudiants.
Vous serez tous appelés
par les commissions d'accompagnement.
On ne laissera personne tomber.
On essaiera de contacter
les trois personnes.
Non, mais dites-moi,
ça m'intéresse d'avoir le retour qualité.
Alors après, quand je regarde,
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire ?
Évidemment, on veut mener ça à zéro,
mais on a une procédure qui déjà
est beaucoup plus rapide qu'avant.
En 2018, elle durait 108 jours.
Maintenant, on est à 37 jours,
donc on a des vrais améliorations.
Après, c'est toujours un stress
énorme pour les 2 000 que j'évoque.
Et l'enjeu est le même
évidemment pour mon master.
Pour ceux qui ne sont pas encore là,
c'est le même fonctionnement très général,
pour la question des masters,
c'est écrit dans le dans le nom.
De la même façon,
en juillet dernier,
15 % des candidats étaient
encore sans affectation.
Est-ce qu'on a les chiffres ?
Non, je n'ai pas là,
vous me faites une colle.
Si vous voulez,
je vais demander aux équipes.
L'enjeu est forcément le même
auprès de ces jeunes,
et ça me semble important d'en parler.
Non mais en tout cas,
tout le monde sera accompagné,
il y aura une solution
pour tout le monde.
Et là-dessus, on y tient.
Et avec la philosophie
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure.
On suivra évidemment tout ça
dans les prochains jours.
Dernier élément qu'on peut évoquer,
la question de l'alimentation.
J'aurais deux questions
pour terminer cette interview.
Ça fait déjà quasiment 2 heures
qu'on parle.
Le premier sujet, sur l'alimentation,
c'est la question des étudiants.
Très rapidement sur ce point-là,
vous aviez annoncé lors de la période
du Covid, 2021,
les repas à 1 euro dans les CROUS.
L'enjeu était assez simple :
faire en sorte que les élèves boursiers
et ceux qui en font la demande,
s'ils sont en difficulté financière,
puissent avoir des repas à 1 euro
au sein de ces restaurants universitaires.
Deux enjeux très rapidement là-dessus.
Déjà, la question de sa prolongation,
est-ce que ça va être prolongé ?
Et une question de mise en place.
On a eu beaucoup de retours de personnes
qui étaient encore en attente,
qui n'étaient pas boursiers,
mais avaient fait la demande,
peut-être faute de personnel
ou simplement de retours
pour bénéficier de ces aides-là ?
Est-ce qu'ils vont être prolongés,
ces repas à 1 euro
pour les boursiers
et les personnes dans le besoin ?
Et comment est-ce que ça va évoluer ?
D'abord, l'alimentation des jeunes,
c'est un point sur lequel on a essayé
de faire d'énormes efforts.
Le petit déjeuner à l'école,
c'est un point fondamental.
La cantine à 1 euro.
Pour ceux qui ont des cantines.
Oui, mais pour les écoles, les collèges
et lycées, c'est un point fondamental.
On a 4 000 communes
qui sont engagées dans ce programme,
et je remercie les maires,
mais c'est l'État qui les aide.
C'est une révolution pour qu'on ait
des enfants qui mangent bien.
Et on a pris ce dispositif d'exception
pendant le Covid.
Là, on l'a reciblé sur les boursiers.
Donc, tous les élèves boursiers
continueront à avoir le repas à 1 euro.
Très clair.
Une dernière question
que je voulais poser,
qui est dans l'actualité tristement,
si je peux me permettre le terme,
c'est la question des Restos du cœur.
C'est une question plus large,
mais il y a énormément de jeunes
qui font la queue
pour avoir de l'alimentation gratuitement
devant les Restos du cœur.
Au total, 150 000 personnes
pourraient être affectées
par les enjeux et les difficultés financières
qu'ont l'organisation
et l'association Les Restos du cœur
aujourd'hui.
Alors Aurore Bergé,
la ministre des Solidarités,
a déjà annoncé sur TF1, au 20 h,
une aide supplémentaire
de 15 millions d'euros.
Mais selon le président des Restos du Cœur,
10 millions étaient déjà prévus.
Donc ce sont 5 millions supplémentaires
qui ont été ajoutés.
Les Restos du Cœur estiment
avoir besoin d'au moins 35 millions d'euros.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites
déjà aux Restos du Cœur ?
Non, d'abord, les Restos du Cœur
sont une association qui,
depuis des décennies,
fait un travail absolument colossal,
et qui pour...
beaucoup de gens, trop,
est un soutien indispensable.
Donc, dans le contexte, il y a cette tension,
elle est claire, fondamentale.
Donc on va être là.
Donc, la ministre a annoncé
une augmentation de subvention
qui était prévue et non confirmée.
Donc, elle a à la fois
confirmé et augmenté.
Et notre objectif, c'est de rassembler
autour de nous aussi de la solidarité privée,
parce que je pense que c'est
la responsabilité de tous et toutes.
J'ai vu que des premiers groupes
avaient annoncé
qu'ils venaient aux côtés du gouvernement
pour donner, et d'obtenir les 35 millions.
Donc c'est simple :
engagement de l'État
avec l'argent du contribuable
et dons privés pour qu'on puisse
obtenir ces 35 millions.
Et je remercie tous les groupes privés
qui accompagnent le gouvernement
dans cet effort supplémentaire.
On suivra tout ça
dans les prochains jours.
Ça va faire quasiment 2 heures
qu'on discute,
qu'on a des échanges
sur tous ces sujets-là.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Merci à vous.
D'avoir pris le temps
d'échanger sur tous ces sujets.
Je me permets de le dire dès maintenant,
à tous ceux dans les commentaires,
que ce soit en live ou en rediffusion,
c'est un exercice qui n'est pas évident
parce qu'on a un temps limité,
alors long là mais limité,
énormément de sujets
qu'on aimerait couvrir.
On aurait pu développer
sur la question de Parcoursup,
sur tout un tas de sujets,
y compris des sujets
qui concernent les jeunes,
mais pas directement,
la question des retraites.
On aurait pu revenir dessus.
La question de handicap aussi.
On a fait un choix de se concentrer
sur certains sujets,
notamment économiques,
de santé mentale, environnementaux,
et d'essayer d'y voir plus clair
sur tous ces sujets-là.
Merci encore, Monsieur le Président,
d'avoir accepté.
Merci à vous.
Au passage, pour tous ceux
qui sont encore sur cette vidéo,
on postera dans la soirée, je pense,
un résumé des différentes annonces,
ou des éléments qui ont été dits
lors de cette vidéo
et on continuera à suivre l'actualité,
vous me savez, sur nos autres réseaux.
Merci encore, Monsieur le Président,
pour votre temps, pour votre confiance.
Merci à toute l'équipe aussi
qui est derrière cette interview,
mon équipe de journalistes.
Il y a eu beaucoup de travail,
il fait chaud, je pense que ça s'est senti.
Merci beaucoup,
Monsieur le Président.
Merci beaucoup, à vous et aux équipes.
Merci beaucoup.
Sous-titrage : Florène Fortier